and welcome back to the i am not a gm
speed chess champion brought to you by
chess.com we are here with a highly
anticipated matchup
between international masters greg
shahadi and international master john
bartholomew
greg we'll start with you just tell us
your thoughts
on the scandinavian defense
honestly it's a sad day it's a sad day
for me um
i've had a lot of issues like i hate to
play against the scandinavian it's like
terrible openings really boring but
still
the fact that after today i'm gonna beat
it so badly that nobody will
ever play it again that's that's a
little sad to just see an opening just
erased from chess
i don't know if this ever happened
before so it's a bittersweet day
well john over to you i mean anything to
say about your beloved scandy
well i mean if greg is able to erase the
scandy from the
the face of the chess map then he
deserves to have the opening named after
him or at least the refutation because
that would be a historic achievement so
the thing about this candy it's
it's bigger than me i want to say that
this i'm part of a community this is
hashtag teamscandy
shout out to all you teamscandy people
in the chat all my friends and family
thank you guys very much supporters so
even if i happen to fall which i won't
fall in the fields
the scandi lives on it's it's bigger
than just me well
can we get some sort of wager on the
line here if greg is able to defeat your
scandi
will you make a chessable course with
like a refutation to the scandi
i already have a chessable course on the
scandy with possibly another one in the
works
a refutation to the scanning i'd say on
the scania i don't want to positive he's
distorting your words already
yeah no but to be clear i have a lot of
material on this candy out there already
and
that that's absolutely off the table
because the thing is again
the scandinavian it's it's more of a
lifestyle rather than
a concrete evaluation of an opening you
know if you play this candy
you just know and you're not so worried
about
uh specific refutations that people
always tend to uh
purport to have which i have yet to see
to be honest
well that's a no those are some
absolutely fighting words
last question on this candy but i have
to ask this greg
yeah is my memory completely distorted
here am i suffering from
um amnesia or did you seem to play the
scandi against carissa
was that sort of a gatekeeper kind of
thing where you're trying to
to to lure john into thinking that you
respect this candy and play it more
i explained that after the match i only
played the scandinavian in the bullet
games that's not true actually
well you know you played it in the five
plus one portion
oh oh i don't know
it was a mouse clip i was trying to see
pawn and oh mouse left
that's like that many times in the
bullet stage i played it intentionally
um because uh bullet chest is trash so
why not play a trash opening
over and over i would not i promise
there will be no scandi
from me in the five minute and three
minutes it's not gonna happen zero
if it happens i will forfeit the match
i will not be playing this game two
words guys that maybe
back home syndrome right there oh i like
the little scandinavian reference there
look at jb
he came ready to play today he's getting
ready with a stat line
yeah i don't even know what to say to
you to you guys our friend well greg i
need to ask you something you've been a
bit
salty it seems like about the betting
line that's been in place for this match
so what do you want to tell people
you know should they bet on you i mean
now that you should be advocating for
betting but
i mean of course everyone should go to
the bank right now like right now if
there's
if you're in a place where the bank is
still open withdraw everything
everything you got put it online all
these websites in europe they have the
they have the betting line like plus 300
you'll never have to work again
um i think the line got driven up
because this team scandi hashtag there's
so many teams scandi like die hard
um they don't really understand how weak
the opening is
and they just kind of like blindly bet
on it that's what they told investors in
before black tuesday i mean if you want
to bet on a penny stock go ahead guys
but
only you can afford to lose
john i had sort of i don't want to say a
serious question because
i don't think any of my questions are
serious but
you have a very distinct style you're a
positional master
do you before a match like this do you
consciously rethink
what style of play you're going to play
or do you just kind of decide to play
your game
is your preparation more opening related
or is it more style related and i guess
i have the same question for
for greg yeah for me i it's definitely
more uh style related
i try to adapt a little bit to who i'm
facing but
i do have my own way of approaching
things and i feel tweaking around the
edges is where i'm strong
so yeah it's mostly psychological and
style related trying to anticipate how
the match will flow and
if necessary making adjustments
greg any thoughts on this um i want to
tell you how i studied for this match i
created a database in chess space
all it is uh john bartholomew losses
that's it so all day i was just looking
at him lose in my mind he never
never even draws a game he just loses
every single game so there were none of
our games in there then
oh my goodness
this is great i'm gonna be adding to the
database tonight
it's going to be much bigger much bigger
you better hope so well john phillison
what's the head's head like
uh well oh i have can i say something
about the head to head
go for it john bartholomew you you know
the guy has a lot of accomplishments i
admit
he's a decent player
a lot of accomplishments right a lot to
brag about
everyone go to his chess.com profile
page right now
what do you see in the front page is his
biggest achievement of his career
a casual blitz game against me that was
recorded at the mechanics institute
where he just happened to beat me
he he played that game he was like this
game was so amazing i beat greg shahadi
i need to make this the one
thing that people see when they come to
my the only reason that's the
video there is it's the very first video
on my youtube channel okay
so just a quick origin of hey guys what
john
to answer your question about the
head-to-head i think we played
what one one official match well it was
like a dual commentary match
against each other it was it was a few
years ago ago a long time ago come on
so it doesn't count for your data we did
play in a tournament once
yeah i was black he was begging me for a
draw
i said no and then we drew
but he begged me first we need to play
this man i think we could just
yeah i mean convert the match into the
banter but yeah alas we have a match to
play
yeah i think at this point everybody is
begging for the game's getting away
we'll let you
both get settled you know take a
breather and get ready to play some
great chess so thank you two both for
this
interview and we look forward to seeing
some great chess ahead
thanks guys yeah shout out to the twitch
chat and youtube viewers as well
so
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
and as we get this match underway we
should remind everybody of what they are
playing for it is
a an invitation to the finale because
alina cash and skye has already earned
her spot
in the finals donya john greg
both of them are friends of ours who you
got and why
well i remember distinctly at the very
start of the scc
i predicted greg to win the whole thing
i really thought that he was a dark
horse
not many people are familiar with how
much of a legend this guy
is and his reign of terror over over
u.s chess when he was a junior john on
the other hand old reliable
he has played excellently i'm going to
have to go with john
but by a very very slight margin because
i think that greg is going to positively
impress i think he's come prepared and
unlike lawrence
i think greg might just be able to back
up some of those fighting words
wow okay well jb as we've seen on his
graphic he's so highly rated in both
blitz and bullet
nearly 2700 blitz nearly 2 600 bullet
and greg is not too shabby either
his blitz skills are renowned he has
many videos of himself playing blitz
and i guess he reminded us of the one
that jb has in his youtube library
but greg is nearly 2600 blitz and his
bullet rating is a little bit low
but don't be fooled by that there is an
increment and just a reminder for
everybody that there is going to be 75
minutes of a five plus one second
increment
followed by uh a large uh period of time
i don't even remember what it's 45
minutes right is that right of three
plus one
yep i think that's about right i'm doing
this all from memory the graphic will go
up in a second
and then there's the 25 minutes of one
plus one
uh that's one minute with one second
increment so the match-up
should be starting any second i'm not
even following the player so yeah i need
to follow them too
um yeah i don't even
it's been a minute since uh we've had a
match but we're ready
so let's uh get this show on the road
yeah what does that
what he's fins with a lot of stuff in it
fins it's fins
um fins zero nine zero five
okay too many numbers in there that's
such a john thing oh
how about i am finns or finn's birthday
no finn
zero nine hey guys spin zombie zero
let's get started and they are underway
john with the white pieces in the first
game
we have we have a gruenfeld
on the board we do you struggled a
little bit on the grunfeld because you
wanted to say scandinavian i could tell
we're not getting a scandinavian maybe
ever and
uh you know i want to see a scandi but
who knows if
jon will actually uh put on his big boy
pants and play one but anyway we have a
grunfeld here and john
thinks for a strangely large amount of
time before playing bishop g5
a line that i know very well from the
white side and these lines can be very
dangerous for black if you don't know
what you're doing
but on the flip side they can be
dangerous for white because after you
steal this pawn on c4 donya
sometimes you don't get it back so
easily no and john getting it back is i
don't think john's a big fan of those
positions where black
ties himself to the pawn of the ship he
sticks so here queen a4 takes c4 the
obvious drawback of that
the queen develops itself early and it
could be subject to various attacks like
bishop a6
or even after bishop b7 john's got to be
a little bit careful about the position
of that queen
right and that's why john started with
knight to f3 because we started with a
pawn move
then bishop a6 comes and there's visual
a6 the bishop one f1 would be captured
and then white would lose the right to
castle uh but still it's not going to be
so easy to castle if you just think
about it
the queen has moved away from the attack
but either you play an e pawn move in
which case i take you on f1 you lose
your right immediately once you
recapture
or you play g3 bishop g2 and then the e2
pawn is feeling a little bit vulnerable
yeah i'm such a scenario
and that bishop on h4 going to be
awkward as well so john deciding on e3 i
wonder what he's going to recapture with
he recaptures with the king
so the king is relatively safe given the
absence of
of pieces in the center but a little bit
of an awkward situation black could
later on play c5
whenever there's a grunfeld you can't
sleep on your king's safety
that's true and you know he goes king e2
that way he can
move his rook away from the corner maybe
rook h to d1 then bring his king back to
f1 so the rook gets out of the way the
king slides back
white's king is safe and what is a bit
ahead in development in terms of control
over the board look at this nice
central pawn structure with c3 d4 e3
even if black plays c5
you're not actually attacking anything
because the foundation of the position
the d4 pawn
is so well protected so that way white
can play rook hd d1
and then move that king away so knight
c6 played by greg he's going for the
light squares dania
which i think is a smart approach
because there is a king on e2
so even if there's not going to be a
checkmate or any sort of big attack
knight a5 comes
and it's not uh going to be easy for
white to ever get this move c4
as it's not actually that simple to keep
that score protected
exactly and the opening of the c file is
squarely in black's favorite story
because greg played rook academ
well first of all the e7 pun is saying
he's got to deal with that but at some
point
if the c file opens as you pointed out
robert it might not be checkmate but
that pressure on the queen side can get
incredibly unpleasant in the gruinfeld
but
here he's got to figure out how he
defends the fun does he play e6 does he
play rock f8 or does he play something
like c5
which is sometimes possible in an
opening as dynamic as the grunfeld he
decides to go for e6
and by guesses his follow-up is going to
be rook c8 maybe even bishop f8 although
i don't like that move as much
but he's trying to orient himself on c5
and i'm wondering for
john if it's a moment to play move like
knight to e5 because if black were to
take on e5 yes white gets the double
pawns
but you have control of all these very
important dark squares
on the king side so the bishop on g7 is
essential
to greg's position right now and you
might be right that he may reroute the
bishop to f8 at some point but queen d5
is a nice move
it keeps the rook on a1 tied down for
the time being because the a2 pawn
can and will be captured if you allow me
to but also just a simple queen c4
training queens maybe a knight c4
keeping the uh
stranglehold on the position and also c5
is now
much more possible because the queen
protects the square yep and john untying
himself
from that a pawn um queen c4 check even
immediately is very much possible that
that end game is not going to be worse
for black but i think greg can go for
more here i think rook fc8 is something
to consider
i still like the concept of preparing c5
adding some spice
to that queen side pressure and that's
what he does and i gotta make sure i'm
muted on greg's
great screen and of course i'm joking
greg is
a very very strong player and i don't
know what you think about this roberts
but some people might not be familiar
with
his string of tournament successes but
there was a point at which greg
his playing strength was equivalent to
that of a grand master and
while your rust might speak its word and
make its presence felt
class doesn't fully go away even after
many years
of tournament um sort of dormancy well
you actually hinted
you stated it in the pre-match interview
these players have totally different
styles
john he's the type of person who's just
inching his way forward
seizing a small advantage and growing
that one into a full point
greg is a tactical player he loves just
like fighting chess just you know really
going toe-to-toe with anybody
and you're right greg you know he
doesn't play seriously anymore he's
mostly a blitz player these days he
doesn't compete
in uh you know classical time controls
but a very talented player for sure
and right now with the black side of
this i mean he's up a minute on the
clock
we like his position from a strategic
point of view and we also like his
decision to play brook at the c8 because
he keeps
the position closed for now he can and
will play c5 he's prepared that option
but now there's going to be an target on
the c3 square so if you ever take me on
c5
now i don't have to isolate my own pawns
because before the rook got there
then i would trade queens and have
isolated pawns of my own now because the
rook is on c8 i can just take back
on c5 with the queen and then with the
rook as is needed
and there's a weakness on the c3 square
right and john quite a bit lower on time
as well greg going for queen c4 track
very measured
sort of calm play here by greg he's not
you know not doing anything drastic
i'm not sure that that is the best he
can do one of his ideas is after queen
takes queen knight takes queen if you
try to dislodge
the knight with knight t2 there's this
move knight d2
followed by knight d3 picking off an
exchange so we can see
the positive byproducts of having pieces
that are this active it's a typical
grunfeld thing
to have all of these dynamic little
tactical ideas
so john's got to decide whether he's
even taking the queen or going kg1 and
keeping the tension
yeah well i had enough time to show that
fully because john hasn't moved yet
and this has not been good time
management if you ask me on
john's part but kudos to greg because he
made it clear he's prepared for this
match he was
you know telling jokes but i only looked
at john's losses you know he's taking
this match seriously and kg1 finally
played after a 40-second thing
and he's been immediate and 13 seconds
on the move before that
so in the last couple moves greg has
obtained a huge advantage in the clock
and right now donna you do not want to
take on b4 because if the b4c before
that rook on c1 now has a clear purpose
so you would much rather
white capture you and that score so
bishop f8 feels like a good move just
definitely
or c5 that's what he does c5 there it is
some some scenarios you want to keep
this pawn c7 just
to avoid any sort of trades but this is
definitely a moment where it is the
right time to play c5 and here it takes
aha well now he's got really a
devastated queen side bond structure
notice what greg's also doing constantly
forcing john to make decisions
it's not only about the objective
strength of his moves he's forcing jon
to be the one do i trade queens here
do i trade queens in this manner do i
trade queens in that manner
all of those decisions take away a lot
of time as they have
but i really like the smooth queen f4 uh
robert it's a very practical chance
you don't go into a miserable end game
instead you orient yourself
on some sort of counter play connected
with rook d7 that's exactly what you
mentioned
the move c5 and open the d-file it
ruined white's structure
but it also gives white the source of
counterplay yeah i actually was waiting
for you to say that i had h6 and g5
lined up for black with highlights but
you mentioned rook d7 so
black was not in time to coordinate this
h6 g5 with a fork
and that's why greg plays queen f5 and
his point is if you take i'll take with
the g
pawn and you have double pawns but
you're capturing towards the center
and in the meantime the c3 pawn right
donna that's the weakest square on the
board
it is i think john's gonna go rook d7
here he's going to try to go for
activity
but i don't fully buy it the problem is
if black eliminates that pawn on c3 john
trying to
to cling to his party you can't even
leave the knight watch out a knife the
knight
would love to go to b5 into the black
position but the bishop h4 is hanging
bishop e7 the idea i guess is some kind
of bishop b4 but i'm not believing that
knight c4 in that position and then a5
unfortunately none of white's positions
stick
um it's like that i bought this uh
little
sticky device for my for my sponge and i
kept sticking it to the to the wall of
the
of the sink and it kept sliding down
that's like white's pieces here
easily dislodged okay i did not know
where you were going with that
um at first i thought you were gonna
make a flubber reference and something
about robin williams but then you went
with the adhesive on your sponge so
i mean kudos to you for going out he's
gonna make a saddleman reference and
then i realized nobody cares about
saddleman whoa whoa whoa you do not
insult
the banned settlement that is that is
uncalled for it that is just ridiculous
you know you're on time you've got to
fire some early early shots john yeah
because you know how they fight tools
oh my gosh i fired the ceremonial for a
shot that was that was bad
i'm upset with you now but anyway the c3
pawn now well defended
by white but white is down a pawn greg's
spending some serious time here he's
down under a minute on the clock
uh he's still ahead by about 15 seconds
at this point but making progress
not the easiest thing in the world i
would play a6 at some point to kick the
knight out of b5 but then your word
is bishop takes a5 happening ruining my
pawn structure
and there's a6 i actually you know think
that's a good move because you're not so
worried
about bishop takes a5 because it gets
rid of a important defender on the c3
pawn
right and i think it should be noted
time scrambles
i would imagine favorite john just
because he's a little bit less rusty and
that's one thing that's hard to it you
know emulate when you're preparing
is that ability to play time scrambles
the problem here after b5 craig's
position is so
easy to play white's position is
crumbling
in 10 different parts of the board
there's john trying to cling on to his
position but
even just bishop takes d4 here and
anything
virtually it's hard to go wrong yes and
after bishop before you see e takes for
the bishop means protection taking this
and
and rook d8 yet you're scooping up this
d-pawn
yeah and this is completely lost i would
play rook a1
fire john try to survive that end game
two pawns down but
it's virtually impossible john's also
got no time
yeah he's going for this exact end game
you spoke f4 here is probably a good
move for black just to undouble
one of your pawns but it's not necessary
you can just bring your king up like b4
b3 it's not over i mean these end games
can be deceptively
they can look easily winning because
you're two pawns out but when you have a
rook end game it's never
entirely clear cut so greg's got a chart
of course here and go for it
yeah and he actually could have thrown
an f4 check with the rook on b2 keeping
the king honest the f2 square
and that's something you want to keep in
your mind but right now he's under
10 seconds okay now he's 11. john goes
to flag though 2.7 seconds
even rook h1 here is possible exchanging
the b pun that's what he does
this is definitely winning john's got to
watch his clock though
yep he can't beat himself here he's got
to make greg be the one to win
when you have seven seconds anything can
happen mouse left anything
yep and it's not that easy to win this
game actually because you look at the
position you say wait h and f versus
just a you know king and rook
versus uh king rook h and f pawns is a
theoretical draw you have them in the
back of your mind because there's some
strong players but look at this
john building up his clock here greg
moving back and forth to gain some time
himself finally pushes upon
he's going to e4 it's possible yeah he
wants to go rook d2 but he's got to be
careful his pawns are very weak
he wants e3 yes he does and that's why
he blows the pawn he hangs up he's
bringing his team into f3
king f4 he's take on f4 that was
actually really
more interesting yeah wow okay
no time in the clock to provide such an
idea how do you how do you keep really
protected there it is bring that rook
back and now bring your king back to g4
yeah
yeah yes this is winning f5 here it is
look at greg
and rook g6 check now force the king
back and then play h5
okay scanning some time so he's just
maneuvering around he doesn't know
exactly what to do but i like putting
the rook behind rook g8 there's king f3
john surviving with the skin of his
teeth one point one second he's got to
move
okay but this opponent fours underneath
three checks have three would have won
oh f3 was winning on the suspect
three and then one okay rook f1 yeah
[Music]
why is he not playing rookie three he
got it there we go yep
oh my goodness h4 checking g2 simply
unbelievable save by john you know it
was funny you were telling me f3
checking the kick the rook around but i
was like
in my house trying to make my way
through these variations
and i've realized the f3 pawn had gone
too far so once you trade e4 for f2
the f3 pawn falls as well in the h-pawn
that
you know dastardly h-pawn can't win with
just that thing and now it is half-half
greg the upper hand he said that in
their classical game right don
john begged for a draw with the yp says
john just beg for a draw with the white
pieces and succeed on it
in this game too and he got it i mean
greg
a little too many transformations there
first he gave up that past month for the
the h fun and i think he spent a little
bit too long moving back and forth
not kind of deciding on something and
then he stumbled a little bit
mixing up a couple of different plants
but john at one point went down to 0.01
seconds
incredible composure to save that
position especially given so many people
watching
that's gotta be so nerve-wracking
experiencing these time scrambles
so really kudos to both players they
handled themselves well but john
that's that's a big psychological blow
for greg he's got to put that behind him
focus and try to win this next game with
white and this is prep by the way
because this is a pawn sacrifice bishop
takes c3
you take back on c3 the d-pawn knight
takes e4 but the point is that all of a
sudden
white gets two bishops against two
knights in open space
the black king may not find the easiest
shelter um
but you know you you don't play a line
like this and i'm trying to remember the
players i want to see it's like a
navarro game or something i'm
i'm misremembering at the moment but
bishop takes c3 dc3 knight takes e4 just
oop
all right grab the pawn e5 knight takes
e4 it's just an option to steal a pawn
here down here
yeah and john going for e5 that's a
pretty bold move
because you know his his pieces aren't
entirely developed i think he's got a
castle here because if you take on c3
now that's just not an option
and for greg you can just play d3
because that creates an additional
possibility of bishop h6 not technically
a threat
because knight e8 saves the exchange but
i really don't know who's better yeah
it's hard to evaluate this position
very complicated it might just be kind
of equal but i like greg's position here
i think he's got a lot of dynamic
chances
and look at the time danya so we see the
position where there's this black bishop
on d4
which at first glance it may look good
it's an advanced piece
but at the same time it's like it's kind
of stuck there um you know if you ever
take on e4 with the pawn i could take
back with my pawn or your bishop's
pinned
to the queen um so are you going to take
on c3 that's the essential question here
you already have given up
one bishop for a night are you going to
go ahead and give up a second one
well as the russian expression goes
having said a you have to say b
um wonderful expression i'm sure
everybody will be using this
you know for the rest of history now one
thing that concerns me
is combining a move like bishop h6 with
a move like bishop f3
pressuring black center um greg could
also play bishop g5 simply he's
constantly gotta worry about bishop take
c3 as you mentioned but
even bishop c3bc that pawn on e5 then
becomes weak john
john's got some serious problems to
solve here i don't know what you think
about this position robert but
i'm starting to get a little nervous
about john's prospects and that's why he
played knight to c7 because it
reinforces the pawn on good five so
that won't be hanging and at the right
time you'll play knight to e6 which
protects g7
in the texas bishop one g5 but look at
greg go going after this
pawn on d5 so using your idea here dania
first pinning the knight f6
then playing bishop f3 you cannot take
on e4 because knight takes e4 and then
i'm
taking advantage of your pin knight so
what are you thinking about here well
knight
i was calculating a crazy line bishop
c3bc
d-e-d-e queen e7 and now this positional
stack ruptured to d7 i knew where you're
going with it
you know me too well mr hess and there's
the point is that the
g7 pawn is pinned so you have to make a
move like g6 just to stop checkmate
and then i can take on e5 and go queen
g5 things like this and bring my queen
in
for a checkmate i love that kind of
sacrifice i hope we see something like
it between d6
now 92 i think 92 is something to
consider because bishop takes b2 there's
rook b1 you can't go back to d4
no parking permitted because of that
queen on d6 white's rock is going to
swoop in with rook takes b7 and
black's position is starting to crumble
seriously there so
i would consider an id2 here and because
of
the i don't call it an attack per se but
the
pressure that white has on the king side
that's why it's actually not in black's
favor to totally open the other side of
the board as well great plays
knight two also d4 in many variations
right
if you go bishop b6 i go d4 saying your
pawn is pinned
and i am threatening to just go d takes
e5 and open everything up
so it should be six played even e takes
d5 first because d4 there might be
knight takes c4 but if you take on d5
first at the end of the day you just
might have a huge positional advantage
he does play d4 though
i feel like 94 is forced otherwise
black's going to lose everything
but 94 bishop before d for de5 where's
your queen going to jesus
i guess queen no but that knight f4 oh
yeah and that's another
between e6 there's bishop f6 yep
88 manchester united knight f4 and then
bishop b7
oh oh that's just bro hey daniel we're
on the same page today man
we really are we're clinging i mean
maybe maybe we should call a truce
i think we should it sounds like we're
um you know
it's an atmosphere of an agreeable
atmosphere in the air right now don't
ruin it mr hess
well i mean i think john may want us to
stop because his position
for the second game rv agreeable yeah
yeah it's looking like there's some
trouble here because
queen e6 played and how about d6 or
bishop f6
queen f5 i'm trying to find
a knockout player bishop f6 is just i
mean the
most logical the easiest move to play
and
98 as we said knight f4 comes in kicking
the queen away with bishop e7 stuff
uh trapping the rook so what do you even
do here as
black well you can't play g6 i i feel
like that's just
that's just hard carry i mean if you
play g6 i would play queen h4 and then
even knight
g3 winning the e4 blonde something yeah
now knight f4 queen f5 it should be
seven and you can't even
oh whoa whoa what what
i mean it takes no take and take on f6
oh oh my god that's just oh and maybe
rook d6 there no but then
h5 you just missed it he just forgot
about knight takes up sex i think
he fell under the same illusion i did
now black is better he can't take on e4
what in the world oh my goodness we're
going to bring up the analysis board
really quickly because greg
just you know botched that advantage now
in the world
john is the one with the superior
position because
knight f4 hits this queen with the same
tempo
but there's no capture of this then f4
so the queen has to move
and no matter where it moves bishop e7
is the follow-up
winning this rook on f8 so it's just a
material
advantage for greg instead he chooses
knight d4
and as we see in the game after all
these trades everything
settles here it's just an advantage for
john go to the live position donya
and look at this i would play rookie
four takes in a queen c7 at the end
john might have made a counter blunder
there a counter blunder i like that
he knew i i don't like that position at
all queen c7 practically speaking white
starts to
vacuum up some of black's queenside
bonds and john
i don't know he wants rookie too he
wants counter play but
these positions can absolutely go either
way my guess is it's probably in the
realm of of equality
i like white's position i'm with you
just play some kind of b4 take the c
pawn yeah it feels like the advantage in
the queen side is
a4 is even better because you've got to
be careful white's going to run that
pawn up to a6
i feel like black's going to activate
counter play asap
by making a hole yup h5 then bring the
other rook to e2
you have to start counter play against
white's king or these pawns are going to
run up
super fast the problem with doing that
though is i always have queen takes c6
which protects the g2 pawn true and
because
white's pawns are away from the black
king i'm happy to see everything trade
off on g2
and then win with my my outside pass
pawn so that's
uh the black king would have to be over
near the queen side in order to make
that capture on g2 happen and actually
h4 is risky and the reason why is maybe
the white queen can go over and scoop up
that h pawn
in which case black's gonna regret that
pawn push
yeah i mean maybe john is trying to
actually check mate white by putting
both rooks on the first rank
and that's definitely a scary idea
because if if he accomplishes that
white might not have checks but greg
doing exactly as you prescribe robert
going after that pawn
if he takes that pawn he knows his king
is going to be very safe
john's got to use this opportunity to
switch to the queen side and that is
what he does rook c2
trying to capture that on c3 white
definitely in the driver's seat here
maybe takes a seven and then queen d4
okay so he could have started with queen
takes a7 so i actually think queen 7 was
a bad move
because the rook was on f2 before so
queen takes a seven to start with
would have hit that rook and then you
could have brought your queen back to d4
as needed and
uh you gave up a very important
queenside pawn so he
will play a5 continue on the side of the
board but
what i'm envisioning donya is attacking
one of the pawns
and essentially get giving up my c pawn
for
one of your queenside pawns and then my
rooks will swallow the next one so i
actually don't know if white has any
real chances to win this game
barring a big blunder the time situation
a little bit concerning for john these
positions
always start to play with no time
because it's so easy to blotter a rook
plunder a fork
allow a pawn through but he does exactly
that pegging himself to that pawn now
queen b6 or queen c4
ooh but he might have okay rook b2 i
guess
oh what are you scared of there i
thought k3 queen takes c6 but i forgot i
can just play rook b2
yes one it's close queen c3 he has only
one move
yep rook b1 and then the problem is the
queen can't attack the rook anymore
and protect the pawn on before at the
same time are we gonna see a drama
repetition which we might
i think he was gonna grab on h4 actually
but if he takes an h4 there's just rook
to b8 that's true
there's no it's not even worth it
because if white loses both of the
queenside pawns then he's got to be very
careful not to lose right
and if you play a5 rook b8 a6 that's
something to consider
but i don't really believe in that i
don't buy it either
it is an option uh you could be playing
to lose though that's the big problem
yeah i mean the moment that black stops
the promotion square
white is the one who has to focus on
making the draw so i feel like greg's
going to take 10 more seconds and
accept the inevitable yeah we've seen
here it is we've seen this repetition
and
john should be thrilled that he's
dodging bullets
yeah incredible 1-1
thus far and greg shahadi you know let
me ask you something psychologically
dania
greg's had the advantage in both games
but he's failed to convert so who does
this
favor after two games it absolutely
favors jon now
one could say well i mean greg is the
one with the upper hand so
maybe he's convinced now that he can
outplay jon consistently
but these players know that you know
they're both capable of beating the
other
um you know they're not under any
illusions about the difference in
playing strength they're pretty evenly
matched
but when this happens time and time
again it's just so frustrating it's
debilitating
and you know it's like you keep rolling
the the stone
up the hill and then it keeps tumbling
back down like the story of sisyphus
it's it's hard to continue
to put the same effort when every time
you feel like you're just about to win
the game
and then the rock rolls back down the
hill so i think john has the
psychological upper hand but greg
very experienced player he's been
through so much i feel like that's
exactly where experience
can come into play and calm him down
okay
and i think that's a fair assessment we
don't know for certain in either
direction
uh but here we see that in this
particular position
black could consider playing g6 to g5 a
sort of queen let's see
king side expansion that challenges the
bishop
then just you know says i'm gonna get
adventurous over here instead greg is
on the queen side but daniel when is g5
happening for black because i feel like
it's bound to happen
it's happening on january 6 2021.
i appreciate the specific day on 5 34
eastern time
no i think yeah it's annoying because
bishop f6 constantly has to be reckoned
with
the problem with g5 though is it does
create a
slight you know discomfort on the queen
side but here we see a queen trade
and um sort of a typical structure where
black is the double pawns but
the a file is now plugged i like john's
position i think he's definitely
slightly better here
yeah black would love to play b6 to b4
in one move but unfortunately going
through b5 just loses the pawn because
the bishop 22 will capture it
and that is sort of the compensation
there's g5 at last
but that's the compensation that black
tries to get is some activity on the
queen side
but as you said the a file is completely
plugged up the rook on eight not doing
anything the pawn on a3 protect it very
nicely
by this pawn on b2 and how do you attack
this pawn on b2 you would have to
somehow move your knight away from f6
and get e5 punch that move through
doesn't seem very likely
yeah um this is also exactly and we've
talked about this before this is exactly
the kind of position john likes no risk
and he's incredibly good at putting
pressure and i i can speak from
experience i played so much blitz with
him in person
and online and he is incredibly good at
putting pressure
in the seemingly equal positions he just
knows how to twist the knife in a little
bit so greg's got to be
super precise here trains off a pair of
knights not a bad idea
maybe doubling on the c file should be
considered rook c3
yep and black can't do the same
unfortunately because the c7 square
is under white's control the bishop one
g3 is super strong here
and if you move your knight away from c6
to trade rooks then actually white may
play bishop to c7 right so like knight
a5
bishop c7 it might not work just yet but
there's one of those moves you keep in
the back of your mind like wait a second
that could be a problem for me with the
b6 pawn but in this particular position
black has this like intermediate move
knight to c4 to close off the c
file and things get messy yeah this is
the first time
really so far that that john has been in
the driver's seat
and let's see how greg handles a
slightly worse position i think he's
leading the bishop back to d7
safeguarding that rook on c8 in
preparation for potential knight a5
or just stopping moves like 95 or bishop
b5
and the problem though is even if you
play 95 now the rook can land on c7
good point just you're sort of stuck uh
at least for now and white can consider
bishop b5 at some moment just saying hey
now your knight really can't move very
easily but john pushes forward on the
king side
that knife mm-hmm you're you blend both
sides for black do you play g4
do you take on h4 i would not take on h4
yeah but g4 i think he's worried about
is he worried about knight e5 because
those holes
on the king side and in the center start
being a little bit concerning
yep and john with a decision does he
play knight e1 or does he play knight e5
or knight h2 also possible i guess one
of the benefits of playing knight e5
is if black captures on e5 i'm just
going to show that really quickly and we
see a lot of trades the white king will
actually go up to d4
it's a long ways away so i mean how do
you even think about that
but in the end games you want to see
where your king can infiltrate from and
clearing that square
for your king is actually quite valuable
in certain situations
you're absolutely right you've opened my
eyes up to this robert to a degree
forecasting what happens if all the
pieces are traded and we have a pawn end
game or we have a bishop end game
that might seem insignificant but trades
happen
faster than anyone might realize
especially with such a wide open c file
i feel like john did just that
and decided on 95. i think that's a very
good practical decision
yeah and the bishop on g7 with a pawn e5
will be
quite useless and if you ever try to
reroute with a bishop f8 e6 type of
maneuver
then white will play b4 and just say
your bishop even if it changes diagonals
there's nowhere for it to work with so
now john is thinking does he take
on e5 with the bishop which clears the
g3 square for the king so that's
really what this is coming down to this
decision do i just take with the
pawn and leave you with a bad bishop but
leave my bishop also
a bit questionable or do i take with the
bishop allowing more trade he does it
and say king h2 king g3 walk right into
the
uh the king side and hit the g4 pawn
yeah crunching those
leaves just that king on g3 h5 king f4
such a nasty idea and i'm not sure john
is thinking about what to recapture with
i think he was
trying to remember the store hours of
his neighborhood starbucks
because i haven't seen him as intensely
sipping on that coffee as he did during
the first match which was
which was much earlier in the day so i
might finish my coffee
long before john finishes his which is
entirely unacceptable
and this was a big decision by the way
by greg to trade everything off in the c
file here
and now h5 exactly what you called for
but now one thing to consider is king g7
f6 and taking back on f6 with the king
so that the black king can come to g5
one huge downside of putting your pawn
on h5 is that
actually that pawn h5 is on a light
square where black can attack it
but just take on f6 took back with
the pawn yeah too and now the king's
coming right to g3
into f4 this is clearly much better for
white this might just be completely
winning because
ah but king g3 king f7 king f4 king f6
and then the question is
can you use the technique of zugzwan to
force black's bishop
off of a key diagonal because if not it
is kind of a fortress
we know a couple of amateurs who don't
believe in fortresses some guy named
magnus
but this might just survive
i'm not sure i don't see a way to induce
zugsman just yet but
i think such a way does exist and we've
seen some great
with lilo chess right with that amazing
um
bishop end game against stockfish right
that was the one
that was played a couple months ago
in that one a pawn was sacrificed to
clear squares for the king
and here you see this king on f6 king on
a four stare down the white king cannot
infiltrate because this key on f6
so john will maneuver his bishop you are
calling for this
just maneuver around maybe have a
position where black just
can't move right you think any move
you're in zouk swung in that
that's a typical idea in these positions
but oh my goodness robert
i see something crazy king i know you're
going to say yeah f4
yep e takes f4 g3 and if you take on g3
i go king takes e8 and i might promote
well yeah you
exactly the pawn d-pawn is going through
so that's a nice find by you there
and can you if i play oh here's that f4
or immediately g3 by john what a move
stopping everything so that was well
spotted by
you and well spotted by john john i'm so
impressed with john not only did he spot
that combination
instantly playing g3 such a practical
move no need to calculate the
ramifications of that
just completely winning no possibility
for creating a passer
the k95 is way too strong because all
you need to do now is
move your bishop back to anywhere say a4
to b
b3 and then you win the d5 pawn there's
no way for black to even
come remotely close to protecting it and
king takes e8 king takes e6
white's king is so much more active in
the end game the king becomes an
attacking piece you saw john do
just that he traded bishops in the e5
square bronze king into h2 to g3 to f4
finally to e5 and this king is used as a
weapon and is going to win john this
game
yeah and um he's just going to vacuum up
all the rest of the pawns as you pointed
out
i think both players deserve a lot of
credit here um
this might have been more obvious than i
realized but still
to find this counter resource and then
to find g3
displays you know tenacity from for both
players here
and this is going to be another big blow
for greg who
could have been up plausibly two points
at this juncture in the match so
how devastating is this robert in your
opinion
and will he be able to quickly regain
his composure
and strike back no assuming jon wins
which is quite likely
it's so painful because greg had two
huge advantages
and john was able to survive both those
and the one time
when his position was uncomfortable john
converts him to the full point and i
know we're only into game three of the
match and i'm not trying to
prognosticate and say that of course
john's going to win now because of
what's happening game three
but it just feels terrible when you're
unable to
win games that you of an advantage and
your opponent that one time where you
probably felt that
it wasn't that bad for me it quickly
became that bad when you
uh you know overlooked the tactic and so
just g4 now
is good and you can also play for
g5 king g4 sacrifice your h point use a
decoy and then bring your team right
over to the king side
b4 here induces zooxvan which is what he
does
john with a very very practical he could
have gone for a pawn race and won that
as well but
leading nothing up to chance in g5 wins
on the spot g6
or this yeah and the game is over
red rover and this is a actually a great
example a picturesque example of why
having pawns on both sides of the
board is important and we'll pull that
up in the analysis board really quickly
uh just to remind everybody who may not
be so familiar that
in that end game there without the
queenside pawns just these h pawns would
be a draw because black would just put
the king in the corner and stop them
but because they're queenside pawns on
the board the white king will say i
don't care about those h pawns they're
double they're isolated
go have them i'm gonna bring my king
over to the queen side gobble up b6 b5
and
win the game easily on the queen side so
without further ado we have game four
we have a repeat of game two
with this um two knights in the carrot
con that i grew up playing
from the white side so dania i have kind
of a
bias a slight bias for white's position
i like having the two bishops
but what do you make of this opening
choice by team scandi playing it's a
very job-like opening and
by the way before i launch into this a
big shout out to
to trust program masters hanson and
hamilton for the for the big raid
um we welcome everybody who come from
their channel
so thanks again and
um so yeah what do i make of this of
this structure
i also have a bias for for white side
here because i personally like these
kind of open positions with the two
bishops
but look at those look i don't even know
how to describe them those crab claws on
c6 and e6 it's like those spikes
stopping any potential central expansion
so i feel like john is right at home
here but it's a very hard position to
play for black because greg has a pretty
clear plan right
he wants to play rookie one bishop f4
rookie five at some point
maybe orchestrate something on the king
side for black he oftentimes has to
shuffle his pieces back and forth and
sort of wait for a way to do something
but for john that's not a style of play
that
he's bad at in fact he's he's one of the
best in the business
at precisely that yeah because this is
sort of a scandinavian right in the
scandinavian you put e4 d5
white gives up the e pawn for the d-pawn
and the queen moves back
off into the starting square so this is
actually just like a scandinavian
and your point is well taken that these
you know these pincers on b7 c6
f7 e6 um it means that light square
bishop that is white's advantage in the
position
isn't quite that useful what's the
diagonal you want to work with well
actually the bishop on d3 is on that
correct diagonal hitting
h7 but it's not very simple to actually
create an attack so
black is doing well to fend off this
bishop for now white can consider
playing c4 at the right moment just
pushing the queen back
and gaining some space but anytime you
push c4 you lose the defense of the d4
pawn
even though bishop v5 is played first c4
can be played
still if you push that seatbond you have
to make sure that that pawn on d4 will
be well
protected because black will try to
trade off the darksport bishop
on e5 and then go after this newly
created potential vulnerability on the
d4 square
well explained man man this game not not
quite going my way guys
um and it it seems like greg once again
excellent time consumption he's only
spent 30 seconds
in the opening here john well over a
minute almost two minutes
um but but this is the situation where
greg has struggled in the critical
moments
he's either tactically blundered or he's
let something slip
with a series of inaccuracies i would
consider queen e3 in this position also
known as knight t7 yep
knight t7 almost gets that queen trapped
but the queen does have the a5 escape
square still
g6 is a very committal move weakening
that diagonal if john could get his
bishop to g7 he'd breathe easier
but i don't see an easy way to do that
yeah there is no easy way to do that
because you to first move your knight
out the way is the bishop is needed to
protect that knight
and then move your bishop it's a long
story but queen e3
is one of these moves where your queen
can just slide over to the king side
with a queen g3 eventually
and you'd like my h4 h5 to soften up the
g6 square a little bit
of course john not making that easy as
now the bishop on e5 will be captured if
you
uh leave it there and so what do you do
do you start with chips
yeah man rob we are just i think we
really need to call that truce
yeah i think we must and bishop c7 kicks
this rook away from the d file
and says wait your queen no longer has
access to a5 so when i
attack your queen the queen enough to
run over to the h5 square
the only safe square in the position
queen a5 and then and then black does
get a chance to play bishop f6 bishop g7
um yeah also not a huge fan of this
decision
i feel like greg really had a chance to
basically run that c4 t5
breakthrough through and now that chance
is gone by the way after bishop f3 black
could even
consider trading off a pair of bishops
with knight t5 i mean trading
knight for the bishop right and then
bishop d5 cd
yeah i was highlighting that as you were
saying it the point is that
um you are essentially by force winning
the
bishop maybe bishop g5 here is a
possibility but after bishop g5 is
knight g4
getting out of the way of a pin and
opening up a discovered attack on the g5
square so greg
drops back to c2 that's oh an eighth
knight d5 and
okay 83 is also in the mix here but john
could even just capture on f4 and
he's not going to be worse in that
position he does play a3 inducing
weaknesses
but b4 is both a weakness and a sort of
strength in a way if you are not
taking um white star square bishop and
now you aren't because i can just play
move like bishop e5 back or bishop
to c7 first or somewhere i mean
you know pushing the pawns can allow
rook b1 pawn b5
and that bishop on c2 which has lacked a
good diagonal can finally get one
yeah i mean that's that's a very
double-sided move
and g4 is also in the mix something that
john has to
watch out for um although it really
doesn't even come close to trapping the
queen knight d5 is a good move
forcing the queen to decide now queen h4
is possible
bishop h4 the problem with those moves
is the queen always has that square on
t3
um to escape to so big decision here for
john i feel like this is an important
moment in the game
yes i see teddy coleman in the chat of
the teddy who was
a semi-finalist in this very event john
can think about b5 now
and from the black side and that way
white can't play b5 himself and you're
sort of closing down
um on the queen side the you know the
downside of move like b5 is if white
were able to play c4
then everything starts breaking open the
position of course c4 not easy to play
with this pawn on b4 so vulnerable and
needing the c3 pawns protection but b5
is certainly a consideration
and a thematic one but i don't feel like
john is going to play b5 here something
about that move feels a little bit risky
is queen on h5 as you pointed out dania
doesn't have much
breathing room on the uh king side over
here but
queen h4 just there's there it is there
it is
wow you call it i look like queen f3
yeah me too i would not trade queens
just yet
although you could take and play rook d3
but i feel like that's a bit of a
cop-out i mean i i just don't see
a big advantage there even if that a3
pawn and some
distant future falls and here we see
queen f3 john also very low on time
with the queens on the board it's a
harder position to play okay bishop d6
so c4 is possible
by the way c4 bishop e5 cd but doesn't
look right because of bishop takes c4 at
the end
right the queen and the bishop team up
well
on the d4 square and that's a problem
tactically for wires
highlighting the b4 squared but i
understood after c4 knight before you
bishop f6
uh hitting the queen hitting the rook on
d8 and even if this bishop 1c2 looks a
little
shaky there it's probably not enough
compensation for uh black just yet so
um what about just bishop b3 or
something like that allowing the capture
on
um the e5 square saying i'm going to
take back with my pawn on e5 and
bishop e4 is better than bishop b3 but
same purpose i'm getting
ready to should be four as there's
knight takes c3
yes well played just knight takes c3
queen c3 queen 64. the queen was
overloaded good call
but i i do like that idea robert again
in the spirit of making black make
decisions
it's not only the objective value of the
move when you go under a minute
um i mentioned this earlier but forcing
your opponent to be the one
to define the pawn structure sometimes
you know forces more time after
opponent's clock and finally jon decides
on b5
it's a little bit safer here now that
one pair of bishops
has been wiped off the board is greg
actually preparing to take on d5
i don't think so not just yet c4 whoa
straight to middle move and take take
and the b4 pawn is not defending that
was the point of rook to b1
so once the trade happens uh it's all
safe and sound for white but
the question is has it actually helped
white the opponent
a3 is maybe easier to spy on because
the whole third rank is open but i like
john's move queen f6
trying to trade down into an end game
and note that the queen on f3 is so
important to white's position
because that's c3 square that's one that
knight wants to jump into
and the dark squares in particular it's
not that
there's going to be an attack or
anything of that sort you have a light
square bishop
light square bishops cannot compete for
dark squares so if the knight were able
to get to f4 in the future
well there's no knight anymore to talk
about but then it'll be harder to kick
out so taking on d5 how do you take back
johnny with the rook
i would take it with a broken john john
and i have an inside joke that goes back
a long way
um where i noticed that john loves to
have his knight on d5 he loves the
outpost on d5
and here we see another instance of that
now that knight has been very ably
replaced by a rook
i feel like this should bail out into a
draw jon can't get too
casual because his pawns on c6 and a3
are very weak and here he decides to
transform the position
i feel like he's going for a bailout
here de rookie five but
i kind of like his position that pawn on
a3 if he sticks a rook on e2
that could all of a sudden get very
unpleasant for her white
so rookie two here i mean just exactly
what you were saying
and now white why do you draw yeah it
should be
but maybe we'll have to be a little bit
passive don't take a3
yeah do not take on a3 because that's a
rook a3 queen a3 there's queen takes f2
check
your queen no longer pins the black
queen to g7 if it's distracted over to
the a3 square so
do not take the pawn in a3 um what other
moves come to mind though queen f6 king
of six maybe then just
uh some some kind of i want to go rook
f3 check
but i'm not sure it's actually useful to
throw on that yeah but that's what i was
saying the problem is after rook takes a
two
rook a1 second a2 becomes a huge threat
and then
you can't stop the pawn from promoting
how does greg deal with that
is he 17 seconds and counting now yeah
this was a bad decision
i think he needs to take on c6 and play
rook c1 but that looks shaky if they're
in rook b2 there
below 10 seconds now i don't see a
defense he might just have to abandon
that c pawn he wants rook c1
and b5 doesn't work you want to play b5
rook a6 oh wait rook takes f2
okay it might be a this might be a
clincher because
oh my goodness a2 is coming take c3 and
82 john wins another one
wow and that really fell apart for greg
in just like three moves there
right like the position was totally fine
totally good all of a sudden we blink
and he's lost wow so jb
he's um he's managing this very well
here
he's been able to make the most of his
the positions where he's feeling
comfortable
but greg really didn't have any business
losing that game until he went rook d6
check and
in his position quickly collapsed john
like a rattlesnake waiting for his
opportunity to strike patiently
he's not beating himself and this has
been a fame in many of these matches
at least it's it's it's impressed me how
cleanly a lot of these players
are playing john one might argue not
gonna win any brilliant surprises but
what he is doing
is playing sound positional chess greg
is getting nervous at some point he's
transforming the position in an
unfavorable way and
john incredibly precise at pouncing on
his opportunity he's not letting
anything go to waste here
it's very true because right now it
feels like john's had two advantages and
he sees
two full points from those advantages
greg is at two games with the advantage
and he scored only one laptop
i feel like john's trying hard not to
smile right now is it just me or
is anybody else noticing that he's just
keeping that
slight you know the slightest inkling of
a john smile there
right he doesn't want to let you know
that he's happy and that's the sign of
very serious exactly
but b3 this is thematic when you're
hitting this pawn on c4 you'd like to
take back with the a pawn
and what you're doing is white is
capturing towards the center
and black is losing a c pawn for an a
pawn
and then white will play c4 and make
some progress in the position
in that manner so good trade this it
seems the queen
okay that's a creative recapture
he just i guess claiming that the
queenless middle game will be good for
him but i don't know
donna i like just a takes b3 yeah i feel
like you didn't need to reinvent the
wheel here
i don't know i wouldn't take it on b3 if
i were black i would play
i would consider even queen c7 sacking
that pawn on t5
i mean i don't think john's gonna take
it then because of bishop e6 but
i would not allow yep and that's what he
does
maybe john could snap on on d5 take on
f6 stake on d5 i don't see a concrete
refutation but
if he doesn't then greg's got that
grunfeld style play that he had in the
first game with knight a5
right and the pawn on c3 is now a
backward pawn one that will require
defense
and it's easy for black to pile up on so
i'm with you that uh bishop takes f6
is a scary move to play but he does it
she realizes hey i'm just going to take
opponent run away with it he's feeling
brave and that's annoying to face when
you're
losing games and your opponent keeps
daring you to refute a certain sequence
that's one of the most frustrating
feelings you can experience
and i don't think greg's already done it
in the best way now that queen can tuck
itself away on b2
black's going to struggle for
compensation there white's going to slam
a rook onto c1
and that c4 square alone is not going to
give you sufficient compensation
and if you ever played b5 for black then
i can come from d2 to e4 and into c5 so
you may get c4 i get c5 and white is up
a pawn in this situation the bishop on
f6
is black's quote-unquote advantage in
the sense that black is a dark soul
bishop white does not
but it's not doing anything there's no
open diagonal to work with and in fact
the knights are
very happy in such a situation yeah and
you know greg doing what he has to he
plays b5 john can play a4 here
immediately trying to blast blast open
the queen side
but there's not necessarily any hurry he
could marginally improve his position
with bishop d3
preparing to double rooks on the c file
he does play for john feeling very brave
in this game he's
you know he's making some committal
decisions but it's paying off
in the most positive way possible here
in knight c4
speaking of committal decision that's
the offering a trade but greg really
didn't have much of a choice because
the pawn of b5 was just directly under
threat so you think with the bishop on
c4 i would totally take with the bishop
because
if bc that knight could leap out of its
cage to e4 and then to c5
right and if knight c4 bc4 the bish
funny two
not exactly doing so much yet while you
can't play e4 and expand the center but
as soon as you start pushing your pawns
that dark sword bishop
can at least dream of having a more
useful diagonal
and john playing queen c2 again
you know not capturing at all making
greg be the one to decide the bond
structure
i think a very sensible decision because
he's obviously not worried about knight
takes d2 he's just going to recapture
and
renew the threat against the b-pawn
yeah but to me this is a practical
choice just not giving an open b
file for the black rooks i'm sure the
queen on b2 that's tempo move
so rook b8 played by greg and knight d4
is possible i was mentioning that c5
square earlier you take so i don't
actually like taking on it on b5 first
because knight e4 comes
and with a pawn on a6 and a pawn on a4
once knight c5 happens the pawn a6 was
hanging so i just
it still has a threat of course okay six
maybe
i like the question take c6 the pawn f7
is overloaded i see what you're doing
here but he plays 94.
so if you were going to play knight e4 i
think you should have left the pawns
on a6 and a4 but even this looks good
you could take on f6 you played knight
c5 which still threatens 986 there may
not be a pawn there
but there's a fork on queen rc7 brook on
b8 so i think
we both really really like john's
position here this is dangerous
territory for greg
because he's down two you cannot afford
to be down three to john bartholomew
no because again john doesn't beat
himself he's such a hard player to beat
especially several games in a row you
can get one game off of john
occasionally but
if he gets to a big lead and he you know
he starts playing very solidly that's
that's very very
that's that's trouble for dragon and
there isn't that much time left in the
five minute portion obviously time is
not yet a consideration at all
but you know greg's not feeling great
right now and i would even consider
going bishop f5 in this position trying
to change the dynamic of the game
sometimes when everything's going wrong
for you
there's a micro and a macro scale you
could do this i would change some
openings if i were dragon in this game
i would try to trade some pieces change
the pawn structure at least make john
orient himself to some sort of new
challenge
that's actually something that i believe
a lot of people struggle with
is my position is worse i'm down a pawn
nothing's going my way
but you know you're going to be worse
regardless in this position so if you
can change this
the nature of the game from one where
which is clearly better to
shifting the attention to either uh you
know a new file
or creating a pawn structure that's not
symmetrical often that can help
your chances to hold the game but here
it comes at knight to c5
and where's that bishop going if you go
to d5 and go e4 i'm happy to kick your
bishop away
and then maybe play e5 myself so e6
yeah marshawn lynch style she's
ramming through the defense go full on
beast mode here
and here you could play knight e1 bishop
f3 involved that bishop that knight on
e1 can then
run around to d3 and before the end
around okay that's it for my football
references for today
i'm i've been enjoying them better than
your terrible puns so
oh is that so yeah well actually i would
say better than your puns if you've made
any but i try to stick to the chest
because that's what i'm here for but 91
i like your move down you're just saying
hey it might not on f3 it looks good
it's sitting on a square that's
nicely developed but my bishop would be
better suited on the f3 square and
knight to d3 knight into b4
you're just creating pressure adding
some to the black queen side so
a 91 is possible i think it's maybe a
little bit too slow for john's
style he's right in this position i'm
looking at e4
just to you know why not just throw that
pawn forward yeah
that's a good move as well i mean it's
hard to go wrong in a position like this
white's center is so sound
john decides to trade brooks not a move
i would have played i know he's giving
up that a file i'm not sure
what follow-up he has in mind what was
the necessity of that
and he's just taking everything now i
guess he wants he wants to attack that
pawn on b5
no he takes on c4 okay the bishop
isn't that good but you have just seated
control over the a file so rook a2 at
some moment but
okay he's bringing his other knight in
maybe this is actually just strong
maybe it is i mean john trade all of you
but i i give john a lot of flag for that
but
obviously i have the greatest respect
for his for his positional play and
as a matter of fact after queen t5 queen
e4 you trade queens i'm laughing at this
but
that pawn on b5 starts to feel mighty
uncomfortable with no pieces
surrounding it so very sensible very
practical decision by
by by john here yeah knight d2
and the knight can go to e4 the queen go
to e4 as you said then i can go to b3 to
c5 but
um the b5 pawn in general rook b1 at the
right moment so queen a2 by greg
understanding that any end game is going
to favor white but with a rook on a2
perhaps you know he pressured the f2
pawn at some moment i don't see it you
know i'm just trying to grasp the straws
here because i don't like black's
position one bit
but with a rook on a2 at the very least
you're creating some semblance of a
threat
and maybe bringing your rook behind some
of white's pawns
yeah i mean and and in these positions
that's all you can do is create some
semblance of counter play that's where
real counter play starts
you have to introduce a slight inkling
of doubt
into your opponent's mind about his
prospect of winning and the mistakes can
follow now the question would be
if black manages to get that c pawn for
the b-pawn
how do you evaluate that position i
think that's still lost i mean look at
those holes
that greg has just introduced e6 you
know
i feel like john can just take on b5 and
and practically speaking that's going to
be
tremendously hard to defend for black
yeah what
black will need to do somehow take on c3
play
f4 try to get the d4 pawn but as you
point out the e6 square is so nice for
this white knight but the king will come
to f7
and try to kick you out of there so one
thing to note danya that we should
remind viewers of is if the bnc pawns
get traded
and the minor pieces get traded rook in
five versus rook and
four when all the pawns are connected
that's not an easy task in fact most of
those positions are actually
theoretically drawn
but you know there's still a lot left to
prove especially when both sides are
about to be under 30 seconds
yeah i once had to draw one of those end
games for a gm norm not
easy at all and john can gain as much
time as you want moving back and forth
here he's spending a lot of time really
trying to find the best the most precise
continuation
effort i think he ever simplified this a
little bit f4 is a great move f4 oh he
missed
three at the end what an idea yeah hey
man i don't
i appreciate the kind words i was going
through that's very nice though i have
to get
my hat's off there he goes up for here
but it's not the same effect
but john getting very low on the clock
here rook b3
play rook b3 here yeah solidify there it
is he's protecting his
king f3 he's definitely made a bit of a
hash of this but he still has a lot of
winning chances
he has and the bad thing uh for greg's
drawing chances in some end games you
look at a bishop you look at a corner
square knights don't have the same
problem because knights can move from
color complex color complex but greg
here
he's only down one pawn and so if he can
say sacrifices bishop for a couple pawns
that gives him some increased drawing
chances but i mean four point seven
seconds left for john so
all right e5 there's rook v7 check and
where's the king on g8
96 barnes
you playing four seconds left
dramatically 45.
now king f4 two seconds gotta watch this
clock
all right but now the two pawns are
connected what was e6 d6 coming in and
this is just gonna be so hard to defend
i didn't know what the knight was doing
rerouting and stuff like that but
i mean even knight h6 there john is
mixing up some ideas but
but now he should have gotten these
seven immediately because you have six
bishop stick the bishop
he's in the game he's led his king out
of the cage h4 oh my gosh and the rook
is tied down the d7 h3 who takes the no
from d7 or h3 oh my goodness knight h4
and it's a draw
he's got to take an h4 it's got two
we're going to take it oh my goodness
i h2 now black is the one with any
chances when the ponderock h7 at night
my goodness greg what are you doing you
need to win the game oh my god i can't
believe it i mean he's got
free rook get the rook to one even if
you win the night for the pun it's it's
such a winnable position
okay we got to show them the analysis
board we're already just on the edge of
our seats greg shahadi
in a position where only he can win
there is a knight
that is planted on the worst square and
i can get to on h1
defending this pawn and the knight can't
move
because let's say in the game
continuation king e2 king was a d6
whatever you can't even go knight f2
because i sack my rook for your knight
and then i get a queen so that
knight was stuck there and i'm not
trying to claim that black position was
objectively one or anything like that
but you cannot agree to withdraw when
you're down two points in a match
and only you can win the position yeah
yeah so go to the live game because i'm
i am frustrated to see that for greg it
just just shows he's not trusting his
bullet skills and that
you know is a big issue when you're
already down two points and john is the
favor in the match and you think about
it you win that game it's a one-point
game that just sounds different
but i'm i'm surprised john did not win i
mean john had
many many chances to win he i think john
just got nervous he got a little
frustrated in himself that he didn't win
earlier
but he kept mixing i mean so many
chances d7 he should have taken that
pawn
down easy for me to say but still no no
donna you can't spell
many many chances without man man man so
yeah i mean that was just a missed
opportunity there and look at this
position that we have in this game
with the doubled f pawns for black
that's not the worst thing in the world
what's hap
often happens is there's tension on the
d5 square
so white should just probably castle
here uh but what greg is trying to
calculate is if he
castles can then black play d takes c4
because usually you'd have d5 as a
move that hits the knight and the bishop
at the same time but this bishop takes
c3 so he
ends up taking on d5 first so that when
he is castles there will be a threat on
the d5 square i
i think greg recognizes that draw for
he's he's furiously gyrating his head
side to side he's shaking his head um i
think it's sort of the case and i've
done this many times
where you take a draw even an
over-the-board chest you come back to
your hotel room
and you you're and you what was i
thinking i was out of three
winning chances what got into me why did
i take that draw
and it's so hard to play the next game
and that thought is in your minds
yeah and we have an opposite color
bishop's position here where
white is sort of like up a pawn right
because if you look at the material
white has a pawn on d4 and
it's going to be attacked very soon but
that's in unopposed
isolated queen pawn black has a four on
three on the king side
but part of that four is the doubled f
pawn so it's not easy to create a past
pawn
or to fend off some of white's threat so
i actually really like white's position
here
maybe i'm kind of overestimating the
power of
not having double pawns and the knight
and bishop and queen teaming up on d4
should give black
compensation but somehow i just like the
fact that white has this
central pawn yeah i mean
that that pawn you know there are
episode caller bishops and black's got
that solid structure but i do agree i
think white is the one
with a certain degree of pressure even
if the queens are traded
you know that pawn at some point can
especially if it if it lands on d7 the
problem with the opposite colored
bishops is
it's a very hard pawn to get to it's
permanently defended by
by that bishop on a2 i still think that
john's pieces are active enough to where
he shouldn't really have any problems
holding us on here well what greg needs
to do
at some moments h4h5 because then
you can reroute your bishop and your
queen onto the
uh diagonal heading towards h7 and for
the time being
until you can get h4h5 black can play f5
g6 things like that
to shut down and not even entertain that
idea so
h4 probably is just too risky to play
especially with special one b6 there at
the f2 pawn
but that's an idea that i'm thinking
about in the long term
well you know together with that with
that draw for i mean
and investing in tesla i mean those are
some of the two of the worst decisions
you could be making but you know we'll
see how greg
handles this but greg
yeah i feel a little bit concerned about
his position here these knight g4 ideas
robert i just
something about this doesn't sit too
well with me
and well john plays g6 to stop greg's
one threat when he put his knight to d4
of course when we get to f5
so what does white do in a position like
this he goes knight to b5 i guess the
knight on c3 is pretty good
just protecting the pawn on d5 maybe
going to e4 because now that black
has con committed this pawn to g6 the f6
square
is a little bit looser i mean knight c3
already threatens you yeah but f5 and
knight g4 comes in i feel like maybe
white should play d6 and just
throw all caution to the win the problem
there is rook d8 john king g7 such a
john move but a good one a good one
getting the king out of that diagonal
yeah it's
d6 will just probably lose that pawn you
know oftentimes the clearance move right
you give up the pawn
to clear the square d5 for a knight or a
queen or whatever
but all the black's is working well
together and there's no attack
for white to take advantage of so queen
e2 played
maybe let me ask you something so you
know you talk about knight g4 ideas
you're talk we're talking about the d5
pawn
it just feels like the longer the game
continues sort of the more
white has going for him in episode when
you have the past pawn
so kind of what's your psychology like
if you're taking this position from the
black side
well i would actually orient myself
toward an attack on the king i feel like
white's king is far from safe here so
what i would try to do
is maybe go rookie eight and then go f5
knight g4 a little bit anti-positional
because it introduces
more weaknesses on my own king side but
if you can get a knight on g4 and a
queen on d6
that's going to be very hard to defend
against because g3
makes you know a host of other
weaknesses there remember obviously
colored bishops
it's not it not only lends draws
tendencies to the position we've
discussed this before
in a middle game it lends a distinctly
tactical
you know tactical aura to the position
because a bishop
operates uncontested on a diagonal if
that diagonal
has to do with the safety of the king
that's
pretty hard to deal with so i would play
rookie i would go for the attack here
if i were john and i was just chasing
the knight around i like what you're
pointing out though because the f2
square
it's not a you know easy target but it's
something that needs to
you know have an eye kept on it and the
bishop one a2 is useless it's protecting
upon d5 so that's good
but the bishop itself is not very
valuable outside of that so knight
on e4 is being kicked where does it go
if you're knight d2 does rook c2 ideas
d1 there's also an idea potentially
bishop a7 knight g3
queen d6 let's say white in cautiously
plays queen to d2
that allows knight f3 check and queen
takes g3 so that's just a small example
i'm
a little bit choreographed but that just
shows you
that white's king is never really safe
in these positions
that's a very good point but actually
now that the bishop is under attack some
sort of night discovery for white like
bishop a7 knight c5 or ah
something like that right because oh it
takes okay so he transformed rook c1
check but i didn't see it there i mean
even rook d1
even rook t1 and that past fun you kind
of called it robert that starts
that starts being a little bit scary
what does jon have up his sleeve here
he does have some kind of queen d6 f5
king f6
his moves actually are not very hard to
play after trading
but then you take and go queen f1 oh
maybe queen b5 is not so bad for black
oh that end game that pawn is both the
strength and weakness and the purest
sense of the word but the king can come
to d6 there
so queen b5 queen takes rook d1 queen f1
we trade
and then the black king so quickly goes
right over to the d6
that's what made for you i'm not sure
yes robert yes
pushing baby and john wisely thinking
here
there's also some crazy ideas knight f3
check takes takes
queen f3 queen f5 but i was trying to
pull an adam's story against you based
on this classical game but then just
queen e2
yeah you should you're getting too crazy
man
well i am crazy queen too crazy
there we see it he was just evaluating
that end game very wisely because he
could make a lot of pre-moves
if greg does take on v5 does he even
have an alternative
um no because otherwise you take on do
you want to be too false so yeah i don't
think he does
i don't know what he's thinking about
i'm looking for an alternative but there
there is no king of one
walks into a pin right that would be a
great tragic
but you can just take your work on d1
because your queen is no longer
defending it so
you don't actually have any other move
besides queen takes b5
and then we get this very interesting
endgame where the pawn e4
is useful and i mean it's kind of active
but at the same time
it is potentially vulnerable because the
king of the e2 comes e3 really quickly
and some kind of construction with g6 to
e4
i have a light square bishop so if my
bishop can get an open diagonal somehow
to attack that base pawn things can be
looking up but
okay king of six is there just d6 at the
point
the honor shook is on white the onus is
on white two oh that's a
nasty little move but it's very concrete
maybe d6 and bishop
uh but bishop d5 there's another fork on
f4 look at the amount of forks here
nice c1 knight f4
can we i'm gonna pause for a second and
not focus on the chest because you just
pulled that honest line again after i've
already told you not to do it come on
man
that is a bad line you're so much better
than that
okay let me let me take up my notebook
of
robert's comments that i actually value
which is currently empty and i might
see one check the line there wait wait
oh my god wait what is
does he want to trap the knight no but
that doesn't work he's going to win that
pawn on d5
yeah oh that's a fork
uh is and john figuring let's see greg's
reaction here he has that smile on it so
he's missed it he's no longer smiling
i thought he had a smile on his face let
me tell you after knight see one of the
word he's not smiling anymore no ef even
he takes f3
first but john just taking here and that
knight is going to extricate itself via
c1
you have to see one yet by the way
robert this is still king d14 c5 there's
some chances here
yeah you want to get your king in really
quickly to start uh going after the b7
pawn
but the black king will follow suit over
towards the queen sign and win uh b6
even game d4 b6 oh man that's annoying
just
trapping that king in the center and
greg just resides debilitated
and this now this game will be the last
game most likely
of the five minute and one second
increment time patrol greg jihadi now
announced three games to john
bartholomew
and man man man john is just you see
that sip of the coffee
yeah i what did i tell you last time did
i notice that or what
robert is the flex it's john's version
of a flex let me take a sip of my
of my fresh food coffee from my mr
coffee went to target this evening
my coffee hot broke but i got some mr
coffee guys
all right guys enjoy cheers oh man
that is i love your your jb impression
where did your lights go by the way um
my lights will be turned on
if you may if you take the wheel for 10
seconds i don't know if i trust you to
do that robert
no i i think you should because you just
went hello darkness my old friend
all right scare me a bit say no more
okay well we have a position here where
it's actually quite close
and you look at the bishop on b7 staring
into a brick wall and it's pawn on d5
and so john is actually pushing on the
queen side because the thematic idea is
to push through a c5
and um greg fighting back a5
is you can take on b4 open up the a file
and once the
a file is open the rook on eight on
starting square is useful
so dania i see that you're back you you
dress up for the occasion
your lighting is now better in these
type of structures right where
you know at any moment black could take
on before but as also c5 is a threat for
white to
consider uh for himself do you tend to
prefer playing with with this
from the white or black side i think you
know
what space advantage is compensated
by black's easy play i actually as a
king's indian player
i i personally don't mind playing with
an absence of space and i have a
predilection for those pawns on e5 and
f5 i like that play
at the same time as soon as white gets
c5 and in these positions
things can crumble very quickly for
black so i think objectively white is
definitely slightly better
but i believe in black's position in
these types of situations when you don't
have a lot of space
but you have a lot of sort of latent
tactical chances that a file can also
open
notice that white is the one who has to
constantly think about that
because a takes b4 can come at any
moment
and white can't get too casual because
that a file can cost them potentially
very true and actually the c5 of what i
was about to say requires another piece
because c5 if you just looked a moment
ago i would just take and if you take my
knight can capture on c5 and sometimes
you sacrifice the pawn
to open up the c file but it's also very
risky to do something like that
in the uh rare situation where you don't
win it back but knight b3 played
to go for c5 but if you play c5 too
early black has this a4 move
trying to kick the knight away from b3
so there's actually a lot of different
tactics and white has
c6 i want all the c7 with my arrow but
c6 so it's like
can white punch through c5 is black one
take on b4 first
what's going on and why yeah it's a
position that a lot of people would roll
their eyes and yawn at but
there's definitely a lot going on here
beneath the placid
surface um e4 by greg a move that has a
strength and a weakness i mean he's
preparing potential knight e5
but it does weaken that d4 square and
that d4 square fight six a knight there
could be an avenue to e6 and to b5
so i would consider rook d1 if i were
john but then greg has this idea of
taking on b4
and going rook a2 is that something or
is that a little
over optimistic i like it even if it's
not something
because it it looks fun and actually
he's going for it because the queen on
c3
is very powerful there and the downside
is handing over the a file
to white but because there's a queen on
the a5 nice fine danya
and nice fine by greg uh the point is
that after queen a2 queen c3
your queen needs to stay attached to
your knight and black is going to go
rook 8 and take
the a file over himself so actually that
was a huge find
for greg's chances the only reason i was
a little pessimistic is because after
queen takes rope queen takes rook
there's this move knight t4 and my point
is even if you give away the whole house
on the queen side b4 and c4
as soon as that knight lands on e6 for
my king's indian experience
that spells trouble virtually regardless
of the position that you're in maybe
it's not such a big deal here
but i would consider that if i were john
as kind of a practical chance something
like queen c1 just seems
way too passive not to mention that he
to funnel him right
i'm totally with you there also black is
somebody's f4
uh depending on what white does because
the queen and the rook are
ready to open up the f-file and create
an attack especially with this rook on
a2 so i think you have to take on a2
and if the queen c3 your knight d4 move
is a good looking one
um so i would certainly consider that if
i were john
he's spending a lot of time here so he
he must take on a2 i think i might
invite
84 on a date you said that's a good
looking move
um oh gosh that was the most forced
laugh ever you can do better robert i
thought you're a good actor
well i just want to let you know that i
don't appreciate your
tremendously awful jokes sometimes okay
duly noted let me write the second entry
i have a pen
ready for the occasion let me write the
second entry in that notebook well i'm
going to give a shout out to
jen shahadi because i see she's in the
chat she's saying go greg
you can come back from this deficit that
is sibling love at its finest
uh of course jen shahadi needs very
little introduction
as she is a mainstay of the st louis
chesterfield commentary a fantastic
player herself with multiple
u.s women chess championships the poker
grid um
you know there's the grid but it's a
poker podcast that's really excellent
and i mean i don't know nothing really
more needs to be said about jen
except for the fact that maybe rooting
for her brother
is the wrong pick in this match i don't
know i'm not sure jen i think you might
want to reconsider it
of course we're getting big honor to
have so many great people in the chat so
warm welcome to jen and um we're still
going to continue roasting greg
so maybe jenna's thinking that we're
going to tone it down
or not no are we certainly not um your
96 idea
by the way donya is also there's a
knight b5 idea so queen c3 knight b5
hits the queen and hits c7
yeah and that's exactly what happens i
feel like we've between the two of us
we've predicted the last like 15 moves
of this game
queen before was probably not the right
move rookie first i guess was
yeah he kind of did it by inertia you
know just take the pawn but now queen a7
and knight c7 yep
yeah that's not going to be fun and the
b6 pawn is weak it requires the knight
to be tied down to it and this knight
can go to e6 via c7 instead of via d4
so yeah john's lips are starting to rise
up ever so imperceptibly but
i've spent enough time with john to know
and he's feeling good about his position
he's feeling good about his position
right about now
um he should be feeling good about his
position but what can black do to create
counterplays there's some kind of f4 or
e3 type of move just to make john
feel uncomfortable around his king
because you know you do have
more pieces a queen and a rook perhaps
trying to aim at the
king i just he plays that f4 he's out of
necessity more than desire
yeah desperation but it's not
necessarily desperation i mean things
could turn in an instant with them
but you know with e3 in the mix i'm just
a little worried about knight e6 you're
just coming back
because after f takes g3 i we could even
take back on g3 you don't have to take
the rook
black has a very very narrow window of
opportunity here if that closes
and and black doesn't whip anything up
his position
will start just to crumble here yeah the
one thing that
i guess black has to consider is rook
aid of ever knight e6 so you can you
know you're
first focusing on the f file the king
side then you say wait a second let me
go over to the a file
because that is really the only open
file on the board and so if i can take
over that file maybe i'll get some
counter play in that manner
um but it doesn't look like it's easy to
um kind of amount to anything more than
just what looks like a natural looking
move and there's 96
i think rookie i agree you have to keep
some tension on the board
yup wow maybe we should be playing this
match is g takes a four possibility here
i was thinking about it and because
queen e6 there's queen takes a but john
quickly going queen c2 very practical
saving time
do you think that john's a practical
player nah john
would be practical though those two
words don't even belong in the same i
like that
v3 i love that movie e3 because rook a1
was bishop takes e4 what about gf
and then king takes f2 i understand
you're getting my king out but is that
really anything there maybe enough six
maybe some checks i agree
yeah i would take on f2 and then
probably a queen f6 move then try to go
knight c5 and dislodge your
really annoying knight from e6 it's it's
not enough i mean i think we both
acknowledge
that white is for a choice here but when
you're getting down to that one minute
bullet time patrol
part of the game you want to create some
threats and just sit back
and get rolled over definitely and john
my guess after
okay queen h5 i was expecting queen f6
but
this does make a lot of sense queen to
c3 threatening checkmate if knight f6
that drops the b6 bun maybe black has to
do that and
try to get knight g4 check in but i just
don't trust that i mean the problem is
a1
is also covered so white rock can safely
leave the first rank
without worrying about some potential
rook a1 check and vertex b6
we'll see that one and knight g4 check
though
yeah that's the thing right this king is
not exactly safe so queen james okay two
oh there's may threat what am i saying
oh my god i was just drawing the error
on the mating square
and you pulled a video gujarati so what
if he plays it though he's okay there we
go
no he's not me there's a reason he was
invited to this tournament and not me
i'll be invited to the fm not a gm
e6 bishop f3 so maybe show three first
just to keep every square the g4 squad
under control
and then take on b6 i don't actually see
any counter play yeah that in white i
mean black is the one
for the king safety problem and why it's
going to be three pawns off after he
vacuums up b6 and d6
though we did see time trouble not go
jb's way
in that end game so he takes first on b6
okay
i guess you can do that but that's what
i was wondering
one i guess king one king d2 oh i don't
like that then rook a1 for k2
yeah no i agree queen f5 i in the mix
there as well
what knight g4 okay now bishop f3 and
resign 94 check 194.94
okay but still lost there i think king
e3
all right but barely i mean but barely
barely oh my god he played it okay
john's gotta find king e3 here yeah he
definitely missed this because king g2
there's rooks
c2 yes
and king e3 out of rook a3 rookie
through check oh my god five point f6
this is pretty
perpetual no you might win
yeah you take 96 you might be winning
no i don't think that's good no i don't
think it's good either oh my goodness
that was amazing complications and now
john is just completely winning greg had
to see that
and how many extra pawns does white have
a million i mean three i think
yeah an e forged e5 and now
now this position plays itself that's
the problem john with plenty of time
here kingdom 51 check that out
steal the
he gives himself the f7 square to run
away to oh wait a second
that's one repetition yeah careful john
okay rookie seven
game d6 and c5 i mean the problem is
it's just impossible to defend
before trying he's very tenacious yep
rooks he wants c6 now put
you gotta put whoa oh that's not gonna
do it okay that that won't do it that's
for sure
the problem is at some point you're
gonna make the decisive mistake and what
a game and want to save them
we're going to go before we go to break
we are going to go over this game very
briefly here where was it back after
bishop
33 move 33 donnie and i were both
looking at rook a3 check
the king has nowhere to escape to on the
second rank the knight covers the
squares
if you know king takes e4 queen of five
check king d4 queen f6 check
king e4 you can only go through these
two moves the queen takes e6 have to
show something
because the pawn is pinned and queen e3
mate what do you got to show so
king d4 on move 34 trying to sidestep
that check
yep knight takes g3 bishop takes queen
oh my god
you can do the honors role yeah knight
f5 king e4 rook e3
check and mate so unfortunately for greg
he had a
tactical just death blow a knockout
punch
and he missed it and with that john
bartholomew goes to a four-point lead
don and i will be right back we'll take
a few minute break but when we return
we'll be ready for the three-minute time
patrol of this epic i am not gm
speechless championship match brought to
you by chess.com
[Music]
so
and as we gear up for the three plus one
segment of this
uh i am not gm speeches championship
match john bartholomew has a
huge lead he's up four points over greg
shahadi we've had some topsy-turvy games
but when jon's back has been against the
wall
he's been able to save his position and
greg when he's been in some trouble
unfortunately
he's fallen victim to either a
devastating attack or just missing his
opportunity so donya
at this point in the match what are
greg's chances like and if you were his
coach
what would you say to him well it's hard
not to speak in platitudes
um and remember all those motivational
scenes from movies
karate kid movies like that so greg's
got to put things into perspective he's
down four points yes that's a lot
but you've got a big three minute
segment ahead of you
and the way you should think about it is
not i have to equalize this before the
bullet
he's got to bring this under control
even if he gets two points off of john's
lead
before the bullet segment that's more
than enough so he's got to think about
this one game at a time
and when he views this as oh i just got
to get two points off of john
rather than i have to make a four-point
comeback that sounds a little bit
different and psychologically
i think that'll lessen the load for him
he definitely can't let this get out of
control though he can't lose
two more games that's going to be a
total disaster yeah i think i would
frame it that you know as i get into the
bullet i want to be down
two games so i don't know where you're
gonna get those two points from
but you're gonna pick them up along the
way but that way you don't feel like i
need to win this next game then i need
to win the game after that because that
puts too much
pressure on each individual moment in
each game so i think that
having that broader perspective of
saying where you would like to be
heading into the bullet is important
and greg i mean you know right now he
can't buy a win because he has three
draws to his name
and john on the other hand has four
victories so it just feels like this
match though
i would say it's been very back and
forth by how the games have gone
by the score it's just completely
one-sided and john's fail
no i mean i mean greg's got to realize
that like you said a lot of these games
are very close they're 50 50 games and
it's easy to say but greg's got to be
more confident in those time scrambles
and those highly tactical positions
and we'll see whether he's able to
implement these changes as we see
another karo khan
no scandi yet maybe we should disqualify
john and that will just end the match
well that's what greg was saying he was
like i should get a point for every time
i play e4 and john doesn't play scandi
and i also see international master
teddy coleman shout out to him saying
he knows what it's like to be down by
four games it's very tough and this he
just played alina captain sky on
thursday
i mean you get down four games against
such a strong player you may think that
it's not possible even to make a
comeback but
this particular opening by john playing
a6
and having this these structure here i
can't even highlight because they're
making moves and now it's all gone so
what i was trying to say was some of the
dark squares on the queen side could
become a problem
uh but this idea of standard for white
throw your knight to e5
gain space in the position and you could
take on g6 if you'd like but h4 is a
good move to throw in
because h5 just traps the bishop if you
allow me to play this might be trouble
for
for john i mean i guess he can play
knight takes c5
and then he's got that d5 phone that's
kind of hanging although maybe not
because of bishop before ideas but
i feel like he's gotten caught in a
little bit of preparation here maybe d4
in this position
yep h5 greg playing super quickly i
don't know if he's bluffing or not i
don't think so because
queen takes queen and hg that looks very
nasty for black
that breaks like a nasty end game
because black has to ruin his pun
structure white's got two bishops
and he's ahead in development it looks
great for white because
i mean look at this knight on g8 by the
way where's that piece going the pawn e5
also keeps that knight
out of the center and you cannot take
with the h
pawn as you would like to because it's
pinned so i would actually even consider
bishop things that's that's a very
interesting positional sacrifice yeah
just say i mean if you're going to take
me on g6 or if they were the epon anyway
i would do that i would totally do that
because also after fg there's bishop d3
intending bishop takes g6 although or
even rook takes h7 there
right um greg thinking he's doing a good
job just to think here oh what about
rook h
no no what am i saying i know what you
wanted to do i was thinking the same
thing
but he ends up taking the pawn first so
it's even material but what i like about
this for black is that e6 happens there
it is
and all the black pieces are free so the
benefit of giving up the pawn was that
black would have to send more time to
develop and black's already out of this
actually i don't like that decision at
all by greg he's giving john free
development he can't even take on b7
because of rook to b8
skewering the bishops that
and now the knight if the knight comes
to f4 that's
disaster disaster for greg so maybe he
has to try to push f4 through but nike
six i mean
this has gone out of his hand again wait
the h7 pawn can be captured right
like rook d8 rook takes h7 now but then
this bishop takes f2
right that's sneaky so i'm sure wow
that's a nice wow what a tactic
that's cool the second rank is available
for
black rook at the end of things like
this or knight g6 and see that's the
problems in my eyes in a position like
this all of a sudden
white's pawn structure is the one that's
crumbling and
shattering and showing cracks so greg
might have to just play f4 here and bite
the bullet
try to push f5 through but he must be
feeling frustrated yet again
another very promising opening that has
evaded his grasp oh gosh he goes for it
oh
bishop ii played by john so guys
bishop takes f2 it's john
bishop 95 now or knight g6 even oh but
then rook f1
yep got to be careful oh i
okay the pawn on e5 is a target and in
all right i guess you don't see a way to
protect it
i don't either i mean c4 sacks the pawn
but that bishop also has an escape route
via h4
so it's not like you can trap the bishop
there right
and knight g6 is coming
hit the e5 one more time and to give the
f4 square
nastiness for greg this might just be
close to lost if he doesn't play super
accurately to defend
and i don't see how to do that he goes
after john's puns that does make a lot
of sense
right and if a5 in bishop a6 just trying
to get to
these pawns here oh we can't even take
because of rook a8 and rook takes a2
bishop c3 that wins a piece
my goodness gracious he cannot move here
yeah he's stuck so what what can he play
because
i'm just going to show the line you were
talking about i mean that's a big
problem with the pinned
bishop at the end and losing material so
yeah this is just a disaster for greg in
the time situation not on his side he's
over a minute down on the clock
if he loses this game of the white
pieces that that is a big blow
maybe rook d1 here just try to trade off
the rooks or something like that and
right make a drop right your position is
worse so just try to trade things off
and make a drop bishop a3
knight d5 yeah that's why i didn't like
that move now knight t5 maybe you take
on d5 and you swing that rock around to
e8
the problem is after bishop takes c3
black's also gonna threaten rogue d2
takes a2 so
everything is crumbling here greg under
10 seconds as well
i would definitely oh i don't like that
at all
yeah that was not a good that's a bad
move that's a very bad before it's still
kind of good but oh i don't know why
john maybe he was afraid of that check
but there was nothing to worry about
well i mean now also this pawn c3s will
protect a4 to go rook a1 and
take on a4 go off to the a6 but
what about rook c4 there intending rook
takes a4 bishop takes c3
oh that's so nasty i'm going to show it
on the analysis board john's missing his
chances here
i'll show that oh my god he loaded a
rook you blunted a
oh my gosh john realizes it oh my god oh
that is one that you regret
enjoying oh my goodness e3 and that also
almost
loses the game and now it's a dead draw
john realized that right after he moved
and he had so much time too i
i can't believe he missed that rook a6
he's got to be careful now king d3 okay
no that rook c5 i guess
g3 okay i would have started with g3 but
then c7 robert
and and i feel like rook t5 check no but
your king was on d3 so it would be
captured with check too
oh my goodness you double
[Laughter]
ram's got to watch out he's got three
seconds three seconds left can you okay
bring your king up to d4 d5 that way you
just make sure your pawn is protected
you sacrifice your rope this is
close but he gets his king there in time
king g1 he's got to be careful
oh no what is he doing okay he's
still a draw no but it's he's got to be
careful king f2
you have two drives by the narrowest
margin of g6
yeah oh john with a very tricky little
move there rook g6
okay can you do
is really smart there oh wow it's what
what is queen queen no but
he said this is not a draw even though
there's a bond on c7 it's not a draw
no it's not unless someone believes
before check
queen g seven check anything wins here
yeah
john's got a million hours here to find
the move just don't take the queen
right and even that was winning but it's
much harder
man oh man oh man greg with a
incredulous smile on his face i don't
think he can believe this himself
he gave john every chance in the book
there i don't know why he didn't bring
his king up to d5 and yes here i am
sitting in my comfortable
cabinet criticizing but someone of
greg's caliber
should draw that position and someone of
john's caliber should also take the rook
well i understand why john didn't take
it he was moving so quickly
right i mean that was rook and pawn
versus rook and pawn and it's just clear
that greg is not feeling comfortable
with time scrambles he offered that draw
from a position where only he could win
earlier
he just lost working palm versus rocket
pun i mean you're
like just like you said i've also lost
positions like that
in time scramble so it's it makes it
happens to the best of us so
um and the worst of us like it happened
to me but you know we understand
why it happens unfortunately this is
happening in a match situation where
greg
really needed to survive that game yeah
and speaking of the worst of us
big shout out to lauren stratt in the
chat just kidding of course
we love you lawrence um got a lot of
awesome people here today
um and yeah when the confidence gets to
you and when you you might start out the
match
full of luster and confidence and desire
to win
but a couple of these losses just take
the air out of you
completely yeah and right now this
position
for greg is i like his position right
he's more active his bishop on g7 is
staring at this pawn on b2
uh the 95's attacking bishop so the
bishop retreats and bishop f5
is better again oh greg's much better
bishop f5 with tempo
and now what do you rook a to c8 yeah
just stick that rook to c2 but rook c1
holds things together for white at the
moment there's also d4 in the mix maybe
you just rip through the center with d4
and if e4 i guess just d3
[Music]
yes push that thing d d4 you also have
the okay knight d3 player
reasonable move the benefit of playing
d4 is this bishop on h4
is always just it's it's hanging out
there so if you ever took on d4
once the queen captured the bishop would
have been under attack
yeah i was briefly worried about g4 here
but there's no okay queen takes d5
what does he have in mind for this
because queen takes b2
okay maybe queen takes b2 is good i mean
when you have pieces this active
all of the tactics work out for you
normally right
and queen xb2 actually the knight can't
move because the bishop on e2 is hanging
and if you play a bishop takes d3 this
queen takes d2 with a pin
and then you have to play bishop d3
queen d2 bishop c4 and just try to trade
queens hope for the best there
but that structure with that pawn
majority on the queen set is also very
troublesome for white
that's certainly not the best black and
dew i would think
well bishop b3 queen d2 bishop c4 what
else can you play
you have to take oh yeah that f7 punch
hang i didn't notice that
and but it's just this grunfeld end game
that's amazing for blind
i would say past pawns rook t1 is a very
much
manchester kind of move knight c1 comes
to mind
um but then bishop c4 i mean it's easy
to see how black
just goes a little wrong here definitely
rook c1 okay
so what's going on here rook takes d1 is
of course the threat or queen takes d2
so how queen c1 there's knight you take
a knight f1
how in the world can white possibly
survive this
i guess we'll have to see but knight f1
okay greg can also be practical just
take on a3 there
but then e4 oh yeah knight of four queen
d8 oh but that
bishop on e2 in the end hangs with chuck
right so with the line we're talking
about is if queen c1 knight f1
takes e4 and knight of four i'm trying
to you know hope that when you're bishop
one of f5 but e2 hangs
with check so that is in black's favor
as you said the more active you are
the tactics often just work out um in
your favor there's queen takes
maybe g4 wait a minute
the knight c1 oh that's
that's not the margin of error that i
was looking for but maybe that does
hold things together and more for black
cause bishop c4 there's always bishop to
e6
right stabilizing the situation john
definitely looking hard for one of these
resources he could also take on b7
and say you know what material is equal
i could have done worse
and then the a pawn would love to just
run down the board you know a5 a1 with
the queen and push the g4 played
okay critical moment here for greg
greg's got to be on top here because
when you lack confidence
and you see a move like g4 in your head
you might be spelling out that narrative
off this happening again i screwed this
up again
and that breeds splunders of course
prematurely
so knight c1 i think we're in agreement
yep and he finds it
kudos to greg and bishop v6 but the
problem is
once we trade on e6 so bishop e6 queen
d8 check king h7 i take take
like this pin on the seventh rank is
really annoying whoa
oh what a move bishop c4 queen c8
aha but i actually don't like this as
much because i think yeah
it's still black's king is safer now
it's creative
and i guess john is is orienting himself
on the fact that the knight on c1 is a
little bit limited but he can always
evacuate via d3
right so do you play bishop f8 here that
way the pawn f7 is still defended
yeah that's an interesting thought
that's exactly what he does what now
though
queen before oh you hang the knight in
c1 yeah mr g3 yeah
that was close to he's paving the way
for that apon john's gonna whip up some
kind of play
stat maybe knight e4 knight f6
that's pretty good i don't think this is
clear i'm going to play g5 g5
wait g5 g5 just want a piece oh my gosh
i have to show that g5 dildo
kg2 g5 is still valid okay bishop f6
john's got to move his bishop
good catch robert there we go
wow so knight d3 g2 knight
one king h3
somehow i can hold on there and the
queen b7
like knight d3 and queen comes to g2 for
maybe
surgery on that king side yeah i'm just
trying to get that queen in there
it's not over yet but it's looking
pretty tough for
it is white greg's got to make a
decision though he's down to 15 seconds
he's got to move
there we go knight e3 king g2 my guess
is he is going to go
either queen b7 or 91 yeah which which
move order is precise i think it would
go 91
21. so he's trying to get quincy
quincy in 81 king age three quinn f3
exactly let me check minnie first oh
what a mate g5
funneling that king nice move though
bishop to c3 stopping
any kind of e1 c2 maybe pinning the
queen oh i like to look at his client
but then queen d4 queen f2 king h3 i
don't know
oh i don't like this no now now white is
the one with the initiative in some
sense
yep very really three h3 is smart you
can play queen a7 you'll never lose that
back that's definitely true and john
practically five points ahead he's
saying why not
okay and greg's going to play on a
little bit but it doesn't feel like
okay now drop trades
uh another missed opportunity there for
a great job dodged by john
just incredible he cannot buy one as you
said robert
and that continues into the three-minute
portion he might lose this
gf was played way too quickly now knight
g7 and h4
oh h4h5 bishop get the knight back
is there knight bishop takes e3 i'd have
four though
oh he can play this out and john can
milk the clock here
he can milk the clock h5 and hope for
the best here
i mean he end up he might end up winning
this game
yeah knight g8 but the king runs back i
think
john's not gonna risk it i think finn's
declining a draw look at look at sean
he's in no way jose i'm milking that
clock but f4 is not a draw that pawn
cannot be stopped at the end
i was thinking about f4 though to bring
the king back closer you want the king
to attack this pawn h5 somehow
i'm doing what he has to here that's a
good decision by him not to take the
draw
because he might you know with just
three seconds left it's easy to see how
black makes a mistake effect that's a
mistake i think he fought now nine of
three
oh greg losing his page knight five
oh my goodness actually it might still
be a draw because the bishop can give
itself greg london long time
oh my god seven wins again good oh
the kingdom's bad man
mad man man if there ever was a use of
man man man it's this situation
oh my goodness can you believe this it's
so
painful unbelievable
simply unbelievable i i don't even have
wait maiden one was missed queenie's
mate yeah this works too he's walking
into the end zone there oh man
i'm going to pull up that game on the
analysis board it's you know it's
getting painful greg
laughed it off but it is getting painful
indeed and
we'll go back to this position where he
went f4
so finally he decided i'm going to push
my pawn and john smartly
did not trade got his knight to f5 and
the issue is now the bishop is just lost
because after bishop g5
bishop f8 i go h6h7 and then once h6
happens you have to sacrifice your
bishop
but you don't have a way to get the uh
the final pawn trade
f3 there's team e3 and after f2 there's
an g4 check
and actually king e6 maybe there's that
f5 to come so
perhaps that was a draw in the end there
i missed opportunity
still by greg but but why i mean i'm
what's inexplicable to me was moving his
king back and forth
and he just lost to school at some point
john had absolutely no way to make
progress there it looked
a little scary but greg had been moving
back and forth for
10 moves at that point and all of a
sudden
he gave john this opportunity to make
progress and i do see lawrence trent
in the chat now somebody call my phone
so i can wake up
and lawrence is here trying to you know
give some grief to his long time rival
gretchen in this position though greg
with the white pieces
we have the same amount of material we
don't have a symmetric pawn structure
black is giving up a d
pawn white's f pawn is gone so i prefer
white's position just ever so slightly a
little more activity now there's a
potential target on
e6 i would think with a3 b4 some kind of
expansion of the queen side
and if black have replaced e5 as the f5
square for this knight to jump to
yeah and i mean from a psychological
standpoint sometimes this is what you
need sometimes when the pressure is
lifted to this extent
all of the pressure is obviously on john
nobody's expecting greg to win the match
sometimes that's kind of the push that
you need
you start playing a little bit more
loosely you start trusting your
intuition at last
you know what similar comebacks have
been made before what comes to my mind
is
you know this world championship match
between gary kasparov and anatoly karpov
or spyro was down five points of course
it's not the same thing because this is
timed
but you know i think in the situation
because poor would say you know that
comeback's impossible you know but jon
is the absolute hardest player to mount
such a comeback against because of how
level-headed he is
i would count on one hand the amount of
times john has lost two games in a row
so
greg's gonna have to pull something
extraordinary here but he's doing a good
job in this position he's got more time
and he's got a good position
your kasparov is awesome i'm looking at
bishop takes f6 by the way at some
moment just to
you know note the bishop on g6 will need
some defense because after the rook
lands on f6
uh there are some targets of bishop d4
played by greg i can
i can be into that move and would you
take on d4
if you were johnny would you just
retreat the bishop to c7
are you just going to ignore my question
i was responding to a query in the chat
and i was thanking everyone for the kind
words about like inspired compression
i only i i choose one to answer your
questions robert i am the one who knocks
i have to remember that sounds good
because you know i'm here lining up
you know teeing them up for you and
you're just gonna ignore him but this
looks great for
uh for white excuse me now with the
bishop one g2 clearly better than the
bishop one g6
and there's about to be an attack you
think oh this is
no attack but this looks real i promise
i'll answer your next question by the
way robert so make it a good one
okay i'm gonna refrain from asking for
the time being oh
i hurt your feelings didn't i things
were going so well
at least you lasted until the
three-minute portion well it's not that
you hurt my feeling you said you were
going to ask my answer my next question
no matter what so i might as well save
it up until i have a good question
have you seen the movie the exam um or
no
i think it's called the exam because i
watch good movies probably terrible
movies
it is it is one of those netflix movies
you click on a whim but
it was a very thought-provoking movie i
it has a direct relation to the argument
we just had just want everybody to know
okay remember that time you didn't know
who bill withers is
bill withers yeah okay that took me a
second to even remember
that moment because you can tell how
significant it was in my mind but i just
want you to let you know
that there is sunshine when you are gone
so
you know i'm okay when you're not there
oh
that was a knife stab right into the
chest robber
i think this might be the last
commentary we do together so savor it
we still have a final right this is this
is not just me
oh well this position is looking just
beautiful for greg rook takes b7
anybody yeah and greg just by the way
we've
slept on him a little bit king f2 king
g3 also greg's been playing a fantastic
game so far
he's been shutting the gates here and
then king yeah i would i'm just worried
about that rook on h2 but if you can get
it out
man man my man i love people are saying
i wasted my
one question bill withers i was i wasn't
wasting my question i'm just
remembering i'm bringing back just to
the time where
donny didn't know who bill withers is
and that's still to this day i guess
anyway 95 net f4 is one possibility
killing two birds with one stone man
greg
on top here he is angry and he is
channeling that anger positively
king g8 only move there it is player
three or king f
two you can even play king f2 e5 king g3
anyway well the bishop g6 is hanging so
you can't play e5
there we go
[Laughter]
king g wait king g3 and then yeah
just king g3 rook h6 i guess hangs on
but knight takes c6 there that's got to
be good
he might sack on g2 and take on c2
that's probably his like last-ditch
effort but
it's not good enough he break up so much
time
wow he's up a minute and a half you know
what john's about to say
three words repeated finally
for the first time in the match assuming
greg finishes this off rook takes g7
rook takes f6 oh my goodness
four pawns four pawns and basically mate
okay but this is the last one he's gotta
be careful in
just move the rock away from g7 how
would you g5
well okay i think this is also good yes
was that sean connery oh but this was a
more generic russian accent i don't
think
now you sound like you know i said what
is a little bit like this
um you know this is just take the rook
and go knight f4 he's got to win this
game quickly though
time already does play a consideration
20 minutes left or so in the
three-minute portion
he can't take forever to win these games
no anyways d4 rook takes e6 remember
takes h7 check so now we see a trade c7
e5 falls then g6 falls after it so just
d takes e5 black
zignuto no sean he's melting the clock
which is very much a valid strategy here
it is and rook h6 checked first and then
rook c6 was probably winning more
material but instead he just trades off
and
completely just don't get a bishop a
night checkmate greg
how many extra points three is that
enough i believe so
what do you think i think it is so
let's okay great get down to business
just go g630
firstly i like this username mike can't
read but man man man gets me every time
i'm glad to hear that man this is
see i've even started i never say man
but i've started saying it
just because of john just because of
john but when he loses this game i want
you to tell me robert
what he is going to say right now he's
just going to sip some coffee he needs
to
you know get that energy back and say
what three words
oh you see do you see greg with a fist
bump
wow greg was pumped to get one back
there now i noticed greg with this
man greg with all sorts of all sorts of
um
acrobatics with his head
oh man he is just looking forward to
claiming that he did defeat john he will
add to that database
of games of just john losing but john is
still so fortunate
to look at levy pointing out john raging
throwing mice
all around the room that king in the
corner of his room is gonna topple over
john's taking an aggressive angry drink
of his coffee i don't know how he's
gonna compose himself after this
he just it's funny because you just have
to really read between the lines there
it always looks the same but there's a
little smirk every now and then there's
a little
you know kind of a pain a perhaps guilt
even where he's just like
i shouldn't have won that game you know
i'm an honest chess player i need to be
objective with my analysis
let me share on twitter um something i
told my student that i think everybody
can get some value from
so jb right now he is well that was a
big drink this is water it was not
called that down
anyway back to the chest you you're
distracting me now you're getting me in
the the don your mindset i want to
discuss the coffee rubber stop talking
about the chest that's not our job
okay fair and knight c5 played so what
john is doing is
he's claiming more space in the queen
side he's ready to double
and he was hitting the pawn d5 so he
forced greg's hand to play e6
and but when you move this rook to c8
bishop f8 comes and donna
do you feel like white you know how do
you
increase what is looks like an edge for
white
or is black gonna liquidate with an
eventual trade of the road well we've
seen something similar before if my
memory serves me right
where we have this type of end game now
in that case i think the queens are
traded on b3 or on b6
b6 um but you pointed out something
there robert that i think is
is important here which is that even if
black does manage to move his knight
away from c6
trying to basically orchestrate this
mass trade on the c file
white can also play rook c7 in those
types of positions and john played h4 in
that position as well so real deja vu
and greg at that moment responded g4
knight e5 and that might happen again
he's got to be careful i wouldn't even
consider f6 here no
same thing so greg is bad
again craig did not have enough and
knight e1 so
also possible look at him just chiseling
his way through black's weaknesses h5
knight t3f4
this is nastiness for greg yeah that
pawn on g4 is already under attack so if
you play h5 but f5
how do you actually even obtain any sort
of counterplay the dark squares
are all under white's control that's a
good move though because of g3 that
takes away the king's access
you would love to play king g3 in one
turn here
yeah you really what john with h5 he did
that before we see a lot of similarities
with that game in the five minute
portion
and you pointed out robert this move is
pretty committal because that pawn could
later
in some distant future be picked off by
black's bishop
but that's not something john is
worrying about right now look at the
clamp that he has on black's position b4
is possible here knight f4
he's kind of spoiled for choice this
looks really bad for
black you have no space um your knight
f4 just at any moment just a b4 as you
mentioned even moving your rook away to
go knight c5
like rooks c5 to c3 to go knight c5 next
bishop f4 come after h6
grinding everything here that pawn on h6
bishop g7 okay greg's holding this
together for the time being
john also has the possibility of
potentially opening a second front and a
bit of an unconventional idea but f3
then capture it well look at that
unconventional opening
file unless you're john bartholomew
because if you take back with the pawn
on f3
then the king goes to f2 the rook comes
oh he's taking with the bishop he wants
g4 i thought about this didn't like
wait knight takes d4 is a threat right
that's easy oh not anymore
because yeah before it had a threat if
we just go back when we played like
a good point good catch knight d4 you
take on ca go take on f3 intermezzo and
if you take my knight at bishop d4
check and i give up uh my two pieces for
working two pawns
rocket shaped by greg he's kind of
preemptively preparing for g4 the
problem is now
b4 might be possible but is that that
bad though bishop
takes takes and bishop b3 yeah i feel
like
white's got that dark square dominance
after bishop c595
i like what you're saying there i mean
it's just true the dark squares are
totally
under oh take with the bishop on c5 you
have c e5 this pawn e6 can't mobilize
i'm with you but i also know what you're
saying maybe it's worth changing up the
the course of the game now john can play
even a4
that's pushing the lock a little bit
then knight takes d4 is slightly better
but still
i just don't believe in it right
and so 1964 still a threat and maybe you
wait until b5 happens
if you're a4 b5 then it'll do so 95
played interesting
oh that i'm not sure i'm not sure
because bishop can come to c6
i don't like that at all i don't know
why i didn't play a4 again that
expressions
having said a you have to say b just
push that knight away from c6 so now
a to c8 just start trying to trade rooks
well but john is still not risking here
i think white is the only one who can
still contend for an edge
but maybe white is much better i don't
know maybe he can still get a 4b5 in
yeah the more i look at this the more i
start liking what john's doing actually
i i can't even explain rook h7
then what does that move do
please don't sit silently man i'm asking
for your help i don't know i'm searching
frantically for a reason greg king d80
maybe he's trying to involve that rook
via the seventh rank
yeah bishop rook's tied down to that h6
fund that's what saddles
saddles i wanted to say i wanted to make
a fun with saddlemen but i can't
you know you're just talking in the
night you just don't know any sound
music so when i
mention a song you won't get it it's
okay we'll move on that ring is about
talking in the night is that a song by a
settlement
yes it is in fact it is so i actually
believe i know that song
i understood a reference that you made
robert do you understand the magnitude
of this achievement
i'm glad we are getting along better
than we were before but we were
getting along even better when you stop
taking cracks in settlement so
anyway back here g4 by john hey
there we go there we go down here now
we're on the side we should talk more
about chess group g1
g4 see it's funny because you want to
keep your work on the c file but your
rook's not infiltrating there so
rook g1 allows you to play g4 to ship c2
stepping aside
obviously you don't want to trade play
knight b6 you need to
seek active counter play you can't just
let john run circles already but here
maybe take some bishop e8
right peg yourself to that pawn on h5
that's the only source of counter play
at this moment he does it
kudos to greg rook g7 is possible here
sacking the pawn
john has made a bit of a hash with this
and he's got 10 seconds 10 seconds this
is a must-win game by greg he's got to
try to overtake the initiative
oh look at that move can you take it
takes an h5 that's what i'm looking at
but then the point was the g7
okay just take now oh this is winning
chances for black let me tell you this
is
not a drone bring your team to c6 and
those light squares on the queen side
all of a sudden cost why can black
penetrate
you gotta get the knight around so take
on e4 take it and then play a5
maybe that's a nice idea but i like this
you can't take on d5 yet so he gains a
move
okay but bishop h6 oh no
i guess there okay now he centralizes
his knight
he's got to try to fight six maybe six
seconds
a huge weakness on d5 good judge his
chances but maybe he's trying to
check mate white no he can't do that
either oh man
oh man we're gonna have to go back as
you know the next game starts all right
now greg's taking these draws too
quickly i mean i feel like he didn't
really search for anything there
we're going to pull up the analysis
board because at that moment he played
b5
he had the right idea to come after the
pawn on a4 but if he had played knight
b6
now the pawn a4 is really under attack
and so you play a5 i move my knight away
and eventually i'm trying to get my king
to b5 because once i start gaining space
but knight d7
then king b5 i mean i'm just picking up
squares it's not that it's game over and
nothing of the sword
but that's the type of maneuver you need
to win a position where you have a
knight that can go from
uh you know the light square the dark
squares and your opponent has a bishop
that must stay protecting your pawn so
we have
another keracon defense still no
scandinavian all of the team scandi fans
you're going to be disappointed until we
get to the bullet portion where i'm sure
jb will play at least once candy to make
the people happy
but right now we still like white's
position two bishops
um good center and we've alerted the
county sheriff of minneapolis-st paul if
john does not play as candy
trouble awaits because
we have to see that i mean and the
problem and
again i'm backseat driving this a little
bit but i don't like greg's opening
choice he has to win
two games i feel like if he doesn't win
and they probably only have time for two
games maybe three
but if he doesn't limit this to a at the
very least a three-point advantage john
is an incredibly strong bullet player i
just don't see greg making
a huge comeback of a five-point
magnitude in the bullet section
oh i mean john's the favor in the bullet
too you know i don't think that can be
disputed but
with that one second increment it gives
the lower rated players some more
chances and greg is
not as strong not as highly rated in
bullet but what i do like about this
game for greg is he
is well ahead in the clock what i don't
like is
that he keeps playing these lines where
his bishop on f1 which
you'd like to claim it's a good piece it
struggles for a diagonal we keep talking
about these
pincers on b7 c6 and f7 e6
just limiting the scope of a light
square bishop it goes to g2 then what
are you going to play c4 no no you're
not because
the d4 pawn becomes weak and queen a3
just infiltrating
so do i have to play c4 now i really
didn't want to
i would i mean i actually think it's not
such a bad idea though because you could
also try to whip something together on
the king's side for example if knight f6
but i think john's going to play knight
e7 that retains the flexibility
of later on jumping to f5 and attacking
that d4 pawn
which is what he does oh queen c3 okay i
would i was thinking more in the
direction of h5
and doing something on the king side but
it's so hard black's position is so
incredibly solid here maybe he's trying
to trap the queen
b6 c5 something along those lines well
the queen has the b4
square yeah from black but that's
actually a very risky move to play
because once i trade on b4 and white
pushes a5
there's rook a1 your b4 pawn is weak if
i ever play a6 and try to undermine
the defense of the 6-6 pawn so you can't
just rely on the square
i know i have before but you can't just
say i have that score so i'm safe no
that trade could actually
cost you a lot so uh if i'm john here
i'm thinking of do i play knight f5 as
you said
earlier do i play b6 as black do i play
even eventually a c5 type of move well i
can't
because b7 is hanging as i don't think i
can but these type of
moves are what come to mind yeah and
this is why this type of bunker chest is
so hard to play in blitz because
if white plays this correctly if white
doesn't get impatient
you know black starts worrying about all
of these pawn advances all these
breakthroughs
and that necessarily forces you to spend
a lot of time we see a big time
disparity here i think greg should have
done this earlier
he seems more confident he seems more
loose in these few games
this is a must-win situation though he's
battery he goes for c5 we've seen this
before
it backfired the last time he did it
this time he follows it up with b4 i
like it
interesting idea he's trying to spring
free and a pawn
because yeah you look at you split the
board in half you look at the pawn
advantages
black has four pawns to three on the e3
h files
white has an extra pawn on the queen
side but you want to make it past pawn
and if you can get an a pawn rolling
that will distract black's pieces and
this knight on e7 already kind of a
passive piece but it may just jump into
d5
in the very near future rook c1 greg
keeping the attention but b5 he loves b5
not sure that was a good idea
oh man man man well the point was after
eight takes b5 rook takes b5
and then you plant and then on d5 at any
moment take over the queen side and yeah
how do you make progress
black sticks a rook on a6 blockades it
with a double on a8
what does white even do here white is
the one saddled with that pawn on a5 now
you're so proud of yourself for making
that settle again saddles yeah
i think i'm the first person who's used
the word saddle twice in a commentary
the bishop is something i should be
proud of the bishop 24 is a good piece
because it keeps the knight limited
and there goes away but i would i would
try to prepare g4 i mean
greg could not afford to draw this game
but now at night f5
black white starts getting over extended
that pawn on d4 all of a sudden becomes
a huge weakness as well
no no the a5 pawn also was hanging so
nine to five
white's position starts to crumble at
the seams here oh knight d4 you can't
move your bishop back with 92 check
he just goes queen dv queen c7 maybe
is the last stitch but then queen takes
c5
no this is bad john is just such a solid
player he never shoots himself in the
foot
and we see him bouncing on one chance
after another
yeah queen g5 threatening bishop takes
h5 just trying to go for some sort of
cheapo time is a little bit concerning
for john but
it's also concerning yeah but queen g4
knight h6 maybe
uh-huh the queen of four you know queen
g4 khm or queen f6 there's just no
threats that bishop oh that bishop strap
nice move
oh and if you guys are very impressed
bishop f3 54 but that may have been the
best way to trade queens because you
could play king g2 g4 rook h3 rook h1
definitely
g4 i played g4 so quickly yeah f4 is not
the right direction though
yeah you know g4 but then rook two no
now he gives that pawn oh
and it's over rook c392 check that yeah
okay one here trades a pair of brooks or
this
yeah this is all jb in this match right
now you cannot be stopped
rookie this is such a jb positional
dominance kind of game i've played so
many of these games
where one of my hacky attacks backfires
and john just steamrolls me with a pair
of pass spawns and look at that knight
on d4
holding everything together total
dominance it's a night that was
questionable earlier in the game but now
that it's found its dark square
the light square bishop cannot compete
with it and he goes rookie three times
that's a devastating
loss for greg it is any momentum he had
built with that one win
now gone he also has so much time like
it feels like he could have spent a
little more
throughout this game yeah he he had a
hard time i think finding the zen in
terms of time management we saw him get
into time pressure
first then maybe tilts started coming
into play
okay he had one last chance there with
g6 but john
having none of it this is over
yeah g6 threatens nothing you start
trading pawns here and here comes c2
and f6
no are we drinking f6 g7 rotation one
bishop h7 checkmate
yeah you're trying to deliver that kind
of made that's pretty funny
yeah too slow though way way too slow
greg's searching desperately but he no
longer has any use for those 30 seconds
he does not indeed you're correct and
that means that jb is about to go up
six points here and jb looks like he's
at zero zero
yeah and if i'm gonna tell you if he was
down six points he would look exactly
the same
literally indistinguishable oh
man he's just so funny he just keeps the
same exact expression he really does
it's on
it's actually unbelievable he's the man
who can't be moved
do you think when he watches movies he
gets emotional like when he watched toy
story do you think he may have
reacted a little bit with a little like
anything i don't know i can't see i
can't see it
happening uh robert to be honest with
you i just can't see it
i feel like john is just the consummate
professional in every aspect of life
and where you know chase quake says jb
cool is the other side of the pillow
using a nice um stuart scott reference
there
and um well he gets another victory he's
up six points now
and we're being told on his videos and
streams he's super expressive though
yeah he is oh yeah oh absolutely he's
raging and
schmeiching he's very expressive like oh
and this was a cool idea
and then you're just gonna hear that
little exclamation point in his voice
and we have a cambridge springs so teddy
coleman's gonna be happy to see this
because he played this
uh a few times it's only cash in sky oh
there we go the tilting of the cup the
sipping of the coffee
the only thing he tilts is this cup full
of coffee to tilt it toward his mouth
but is he is he putting the pinky up yet
no the p right right the pinky the two
fingers up when you're drinking
i remember that from the last match
and it's quite possibly the last game of
the three minute portion barring
a quick result
man man man man i just i'm looking at
this board here
looks good for white again jb's up six
points
i don't know what else to say i don't
know it's just one of those things where
bit by bit the match gets out of control
i'm not sure about about e4 i feel like
that might have been a little bit
premature
but still very comfortable pleasant
position for john
six points there's no way he loses six
games in bullet right
i can't see it happening john is
probably among the players in this field
um one of the strongest bullet players
and he's just as solid and bullet as he
is in in the other time controls it's
not like
he goes crazy his time management is
good he's fast i can't see it happening
he's also been drinking a lot more water
than i'm used to
because we only see the coffee
mug typically but i've seen that small
glass of water i have to interrupt it's
so funny we scratched
the back of our neck at the exact same
time i was looking at the stream
yeah i did not choreograph i don't know
if anybody else saw that
i didn't see it i was paying attention
to the chess and to my comments about is
that so
okay yeah good to know
there's oh no never mind i had some
crazy ideas there with putting the
bishop on c4 and following up with
bishop g6 but really
when you're up six there's absolutely no
excuse for doing anything crazy
yeah i mean you look at this position
here white has such good control over
the center
um the one downside i would say is that
it's not clear how to make progress so
if you can
get a blockade for black bishop e6 to
start with
you're not really threatening to take on
b6 ever so bishop a5 is a pin
that doesn't actually threaten much so
bishop e6 queen d7
i just play in that manner yeah that
squares
is a pretty big deal and i would
definitely jettison the pawn at some
point just allow bishop b6
and rook b6 also because the a file
opens and that a2 pawn is going to be
very weak
most of the time you're not even going
to be sacking the pawn because if the
bishop is on e6 as you point out robert
rook takes a2 is always going to be
possible
exactly so greg thinking for a while
before
playing bishop e6 but that 38 second
think there
you know it's one that you knew he was
thinking about bishop v6 from the start
and you can just tell he's a lack of
confidence in the moment queen d7 so he
plays the exact idea we were talking
about
you can't take on v6 thanks to
bridgeport mitch
uh for that 100 you know cheer there
appreciate it
um and glad you enjoyed the channel and
i guess you're from bridgeport
connecticut
you're judging by your username but
maybe i'm wrong and
bishop d3 by jb
what's this idea it should i guess just
bishop d2 he's trying to rain everything
in
maybe he wants some potential rook lift
with the rookie one or keep four
rook h4 because okay greg's slowly
preparing c5 but c5 immediately is not
possible because of bishop b5
don't play c5 maybe okay
that's an annoying move because if rook
c7 why i can try to soften him up with
bishop a5
right and then just come back to d2 i
actually would have played b5 b4 i think
yeah
definitely agree put my pawn on b4 and
then try to go c5
and play more aggressively but brooks c7
works in rook c8 so bishop a5 now b6
comes and c by the b is possible
because there's no skewer right there's
no rook on e8
bishop a6 and bishop b5 though this is a
double-sided sword because there's that
x-ray going
on the rook on d1 and the queen of d7
there's a little kebab of pieces on the
t file but
if you move the onions away you might be
left with the meat so that's what john
is doing
there's a kebab with no skewers so
what's your point
man this is this is this this is too
much too meta of a reference
i have some kebabs in my in my freezer i
don't know why i just made myself hungry
i'm just really hungry i have not eaten
dinner uh i thought that this match
would be a nice snack but now it's
getting one-sided and so
i'm just getting hungry me too
okay are there any places open late in
new york at this hour because in
charlotte like everything after 10 p.m
everything that says it's open till two
everything is closed it's a terrible
face some of us cook
so oh i cook i make i'm i i'm the best
froze i have the best digiorno pizza in
town
[Laughter]
oh my gosh it's not delivery it's it's
inferno
all right so bishop c5 closing the c
file i mean
i do like black's position it feels like
black speeds are more coordinated
but is white just go ahead and take on
e6 take the two bishops and the king on
h8 isn't too safe
but i still don't like john's position
that bishop on c5 is making me nervous
queen g4 here for example
that attack could come out of nowhere
queen g4 knight f4 we all know
the knight in queen tandem is incredibly
powerful greg's gotta move so he is
you can just sense he's not confident in
his ideas queen g4 is a move i would
make in three seconds
the queen's queen d2 perhaps just
pinning that knight
to the rocket bishop before actually but
still if we need seven okay that's
sensible as well they've been aiming for
g5 he's just freeing up his knight
that's the key idea here
so knight f4 comes the tempo but the
queen f3 hits the net and f4 hits the
pawn f7 behind it
and black's king is not exactly very
safe because
also queen g5 no knight g6 is definitely
not the way now e6 e6
but that pawns pins are nine feet okay
but so i feel like queen g5 created that
threat against the undefended c1 rook
oh good call knight f8 is a great move
though
here he doesn't want to ignite too much
time look at his clock five seconds
he's going okay he was going for the
rook and now he takes here and then
knight f4 comes in so your idea
and long last but g3 stabilizes the
situation knight f4 now that looks
devastating
but there's g3 here because he's holding
things together all right
then quinny check you gotta watch
everybody john
and greg's got two seconds queen g3 yeah
that's a bishop d3
oh missed by both
okay so what a 1964 the free point oh my
god
[Music]
oh my god you just want a free piece
john has
shaking his head with the that smile he
feels bad
but that is the story of the match right
then and there
oh well greg jihadi he just can do
nothing but laugh at his own demise in
this match and
we will take a quick breather because my
heart aches for
greg and when we return we will see the
bullet portion of this match john
john bartholomew up so many points that
it feels like it's already his match to
win
we'll see if that's the case when we
return just a few minutes is i am not a
gm speeches championship match brought
to you by trust.com
[Music]
so
and as we return the question on
everyone's mind that i have in fact
asked the chat is dania how many
scandies are we about to see
in the bull abortion i think we're going
to see i just feel like john
is not in a scandi frame of mind today i
think we're going to see one
just so he keeps you know this country
from entering a revolution
but i feel like he's gonna go by the if
it ain't broke don't fix it mindset and
he's gonna keep playing carl so i think
we're gonna see a standing in the first
game that greg plays e4
and then i'm sad to report but i don't
think he's gonna keep playing this candy
that's just my take
and the problem i hate to be the bearer
of bad titans of course well john
doesn't play e4
because then greg would play the scandy
against him and show him his boss
or try to i should say uh but yeah you
know he's gonna let the whole region
down
zlatan ibrahimovic will never forgive
him magnus carlson will
uh no longer associate with john
bartholomew even though
max carlson himself has used the scandy
he beat five under caruana in the tromso
olympiad
and then drew him in another game with
the scandi so if magnus carlsen could do
it against five minute carwana
there's no excuse for jumper thumbs
shall we say this will be scandalous
oh my gosh i liked you so much more
while we were on break
what happened donya what did you do
let's get these games
don't perform under pressure let's get
them going because we want the mystery
to be resolved i think we can agree on
that and here we go pizza
no no no no no he played d5 in the first
move so it's kind of like a scandal
i don't think that qualifies greg how
could you oh
that is disappointing so now we get the
b3 systems
it's gonna take a while because you know
greg needs to win every single game
right he does i mean and he needs to
start quickly there is technically
enough time let's be clear about that
there is enough time but if he loses
even one more game the match is over and
here he allows a4
that's this is a structure that i've
played against john because i played b3
pretty often against him
john is really good in these structures
okay that's a
watch out for knight takes g3 by the way
the queen 97 pins the pawn f2
so you would like to play b4 and keep
the queen side closed but then you oh
okay taking that wish now before it is
possible yeah a3 cementing
that pawn structure the pawn on b4 is a
little bit weak yeah this is very
double-edged greg
certainly shouldn't trade the queens now
he plays
three yep and so would you play g4 kick
that knight
yeah i would actually go for king side
play here just go for the throw g4
knight g5 and then sack something on e6
g4 h for h5 is pushing everything yeah i
wouldn't play on the queen so the
problem is if you ever played b5
black can leap into c5 with his other
knight here we already see john reaping
the rewards greg's rogues
just don't look like they carry a lot of
strength
doubled up on the on the closed b file
like that although what about some kind
of knight h2ni g forest sort of maneuver
especially you know that b7 is hanging
knight h2 is not going to
i like it opening up that bishop the
problem is there's knight t4 knight e4
yeah but then
[Music]
exactly yeah i got nothing for you
knight
ford's traps knight is just very strong
bishop takes beef
seven and yeah thank you thank you i'm
just saying
oh they both missed it it hurts still
winning
still winning though it hurts they both
missed the fork with me too
oh oh my god and greg i think he's
taking a deep breath but it's still bad
rook b5 though
yeah let me tell you robert rook takes
c5 and 94 ideas potentially
we have six coming in oh yeah this is
heating up here
and it's actually very important that
the king of the h2 square to escape to
because now that there's a check you
know it's one check good for you oh take
the queen take out c5
that's actually good choice okay very
practical
wow john is he's a sneaky guy
takes f2 is also in the mix can you get
rook c7 and take on f7
oh he was trying to take on e6 but look
at that you take it outside with check
rook f2 and rp2 this doesn't look good
oh whoa what is that you're gonna have
someone check that's a bad move for sure
what is he doing he loses the rook and
he loses that game
just blew it right there and it's
actually checkmate after king d8 there
john
trying to prolong the game obviously oh
yeah 96 we're going to fade with me good
call
why is that rook d2 come on he's got to
do he's got to get on with this he
cannot waste
a single second and rook anywhere on the
seventh right we check my next move
rook anywhere anyone oh my goodness
checkmate in one i cannot believe it
there's clearly no squares for the king
he lets johnny make the clock a little
bit further wait don't resign what a
gentleman
what did he is a gentleman he didn't
have to maybe not so scholarly in this
instance but gentlemanly for sure
greg with another fist bump yeah let me
tell you if he wins one more well
oh it's still a six point game i thought
it was a six point game to start but it
was no
no and daniel that wasn't a fist bump
that was a crossfit exercise
oh well i wouldn't know what i i mean
nor would i but i see greg posting that
all the time
all right another one of these queen
trade positions where white is slightly
better
sorry robert but greg why is he going
for this end game
um don't ask me man i asked you the
questions that we
said it is you've learned finally we're
only in the last semi-final of this
event
heading towards the finals and you
finally have learned
well better late than never as they say
now e4 is possible
john's got that crunch in the center f45
i i like that way i rarely compliment
you but got that crunch in the center
that's a really
well phrased description of this
position thank you well i was
there was a a very high level pun
contained in that
but you wouldn't recognize it crunched
jim no i know i i
i now understand what you were saying
after you said there was some high level
thing but it was actually
so ridiculous and unnecessary that i
just
you know wait is there gonna be a mate
on the g5 working there might be rook up
four rook g4
rook ah you know what's interesting rook
f4 h5 or cut five
but john going straight for the throat
rook h5 rock h6 and bishop h7
no rook rook okay
yeah that way oh my god bishop major
seven mates oh
lord what a devil oh my gosh and jb
finds it oh and that king subjected to
workout at la fitness right there rook
she gave me
it that king wishes it could escape to
the west coast because oh
bishop g7 checkmated one that's so sad
he didn't want me to won
oh my gosh what a devilish sequence by
john
all of a sudden in an end game you check
made seven like five moves
hey you the the traditionalist would be
mad at you for saying an end game
because when there's two rooks in the
minor pieces
that's a queenless middle game oh my
sincere apologies to the traditionalists
i've been threatened
by viewers that they would stop watching
my commentary if i called positions of
the end games i was like
really it's like you know a minor point
here but i've taken it to heart
okay
why are we not getting a scandy i don't
know this is ridiculous there's nothing
on the line anymore it's clear that john
will win this match
i mean i think it's safe to say
that doesn't mean anybody should go
anywhere but i mean
seven points in 19 minutes
tracy mcgrady made a bigger comeback i
was at the spurs i was about to say it
so i'm glad you said it did you
actually worry about somebody that's 100
about to say oh my goodness man
um there's also reggie miller against my
beloved right the three-pointers
um don't bring that up in my presence i
can bring it up you can't
but tracy mcgrady one was was a good
call the thing is robert
i don't even need to think because i the
knicks have lost so many games
and they've won so few that i can
mention any team against the knicks and
chances are they made a big comeback
against them at some point
you're not wrong that's what hurts the
most but don't touch the warriors though
that is sacrosanct
um and john is just i mean he is
scooping up ripping him apart here in
this structure
scooping up pawns and okay that's
queen a4 greg is a little tilted i think
so what's the material a queen for
a in a pawn for rook and a bishop that's
not enough
and knight takes g3 i have to work up
one is just lights out that takes g3
and the pawn is pinned oh my goodness
that is a massacre
massacre right there knight f1 even it's
practical play by john
man man man man main man right guys
doing doing pretty well so far but
let's not relax prematurely just take
another refill of my espresso at
starbucks guys
all right guys oh look
that was a smile i saw a smile i saw a
smile smile exciting
i did see a smile bartholomew smile
sighting i mean that's it
my job as a commentator is doane i have
seen john bartholomew
thank you everybody no i'm just kidding
robert and it's a relief i finally get
to commentate on my own as i've always
desired to
see you later robert good job you know
i'm glad that you're glad you're honest
with me that's the first
step to having a good you know
commentating partnership is that you're
honest that you want to kick me out it's
fine
i see how it is dania i thought that i
provided at least a you know a smidgen
of entertainment value
and some quality announcements here and
there smidgeon is about right
okay good we're on the same page see
that we're back on the same page
this rook on d3 queen on d1
configuration leaves quite a bit to be
desired
uh and queen e4 that's a nice move
bishop g2 though
watch it bishop back notice bishop takes
d5 there's knight h4
yep so what can you do instead
queen b4 yeah now that queen is like
rookie
i like how greg is handling this the
problem is if john plays e4 and knight
c4 things could get
things could go sour very quickly here
for john even the a3 is an idea here
because queen takes a three
there's knight c4 oh that's nice what's
knight c4 immediately
well now there's no knight c4 was bishop
a6 covers the square
f4 e55 though f4 there's gonna be some
kind of knight takes d5
oh cool i would play rookie seven back
just like preemptively like please play
out four
oh good now okay greg scratch's
getting worked on here queen c3 take
take 965 the pawn is pinned
how about knight b1 and knight c3 that's
i don't like rookie 7 there though
agreed he's trying to just pin if you
take on c4 rook c7 or c8 gonna stop
pinning down the c line yeah and john
taking his sweet time here yeah this is
definitely from a practical perspective
harder to play for white because oh and
brave brave bartholomew
rook c7 and maybe double ruler rooks and
vince
three i guess oh no but i mean white is
clearly william
no but i don't know what is saying i
mean together with dingley
he doesn't know what he's talking about
oh my gosh that is awesome
so awesome and he transfers his rook to
c7 can you save that bishop on c4
um the answer is no but i'll say yes
just to make you feel better about it
rook c8
knight takes d5 okay oh just take and
take on c4 is there
there's nothing going on on the e file
because that knight's defending the
square
routine c4 just wins yeah you have d7
under control because the knight
covering the square so there's no d7 and
you're up a piece
but greg i'm sorry to say but when
you're
not trusting yourself even simple
conversions can become difficult
speaking from experience
it's true you're getting frustrated
you're seeing every single
game i'm going to lose i have been
losing and that's a good move though
f5 nicely done by greg
very clean rook take
not rook takes e6 you're nice under
attack okay queen c6
okay that loses oh gosh oh
man john losing the house here
and f2 check coming if you don't drink
let's see another smile from mr
bartholomew here no no more smiles
he's all serious at this point and
nothing no reaction not a nod not a head
shake not a smile
literally expressionless and
when are we gonna get is scandy well
greg it's a
ball is in great score right now he's
the one playing one b3
and chickening out this is extremely
robert you know what's unacceptable is
in the interviews he was talking up a
storm about he would
the scandinavian would be would be named
the shahada navy i mean he was talking
talking talking now when he has a chance
to play e4
he doesn't even let jon play an opening
which he's clearly refuted
that's going to be our first question
when we get to the interviews is about
why greg did not play e4 and allow a
scandinavian because he did talk a big
game
and then when it came down to the bullet
where he was saying it's the only time
he would play
the scandi himself there's been no
scandinavia
yeah sorry oh go ahead yeah i'm saying
you know what they say
he who laughs last laughs longest
and john may be talking less during the
interviews but he's letting his move do
the talking here
this is very true and for
greg you know i have to wonder what's
going on why no skinny maybe because
he's losing the match
he doesn't also want to lose in the
scandi so that way it's you know adding
insult to injury but i want to see some
scandinavian d4 is
a beautiful piece it is and john again
with those knights on the outpost
defended by the pawn on t5 even though
it's not protected by a pawn you still
can't reach that knight and look at this
domination doubling on the a file
crashing through once again in the
structure
it's easy to play and yeah pointing out
the knight on d4
safe there can't be attacked the only
ways you know key one king d2
e3 but that time okay do i take on a2
and then go 92 check or something
um i would yeah just king f6 biting the
time because
light has no way to apply pressure on
the oh but now it takes a 92 knight
takes f4
no it was mate oh wait okay three i was
going to 92 rookie champion would that
have been a mouse loop no
maybe he just won rugby seven the rubber
that was some ideas i guess but then 92
rook d1 was going for me he's still
going for me yeah he is
oh ninety two me too oh another fork and
this time john doesn't miss it
rook d1 mate oh rushing crushing
crushing
oh man no man
man man man man man man man
four times well that's a new one what is
there even to say here
i mean it's one of those things that we
always talk about this robert now some
of these lopsided matches
you know it's easy to think that oh from
the very start
it was just one win after another but
these things take place gradually
first you show a little sign of weakness
remember those first two games when greg
had two chances to win
didn't capitalize yep i just feel like
that created that shadow
in his mind over the whole match and he
just wasn't quite the same
in terms of confidence in terms of
crispness in terms of sharpness and john
on the other hand
he got better and better as the match
went on like some bottle of fine wine
yeah john has been great and let me ask
you dania you know
we'll talk about this more in depth in a
bit but now that we know john
bartholomew is moving on to the final
taking on olena kashminskaya
kashlinskaya right that's it i see i
changed it because i remembered
you uh kind of scolding me
thank you robert well i appreciate that
you take my comments to heart that means
a lot to me
you've earned yourself one more
commentary with me
well i'm glad that the next one is the
final look we have two all right
greg rookie stacy doing short work there
and queen takes f1 is going to be oh no
that's not possible though
g6 how do you win wait it would that
would be ridiculous if all of a sudden
it's white winning you know queen no it
can't be i mean there's no threats and
greg could worse comes to worse
okay but where is the where is the win
queen f6 rook h3 then queen f1 that
would be sick
oh nice distracting get out of there
yeah that's right
because rookie 3 is tempting here right
to just like get discoveries
yeah play broken tree and then queen
takes f1 the switchback but
what if white takes and then goes rook
h3 yeah
and man there's some bishop discoveries
and there's a little
white square the other rooks are in a
light square oh my god
man oh john
rook h3 on page 3 john
me and man hey you got johnny man what
did i do
man man oh my god oh gosh and
now it looks like black should be much
better activity but
with john he's so resilient rookie one
it's not that clear bishop takes
c5 is not so clear because of rookie
five
rookies three king g8 okay you're going
to escape for now bishop takes d5 now
though got to be winning yeah 93.
and i can't believe how long john is
surviving it's like every time greg
makes a move now it's winning
and john finds a resource knight d3
perhaps is the only option i don't want
to see
any other moves here i don't either he's
got a he's got to do it
and there it is rook h3 and 97
picking up material nasty rook h3 97
fourth down oh john oh john
i feel like john is just he's taking the
foot off the gas pedal but
deservedly so i feel like there's almost
a checkmate there with knight d3s in
there this is still not clear it's
amazing
chess is a draw robert c6 instead of
bishop v6 gave black some chances yeah
to win that game but let's just say
we've seen higher quality bullet games
we've also seen rook and pawn beat rook
and pawn so that is true
this game is full of fight king g5 king
f6 oh no
g6 please no don't lose this greg
rook c8 okay all right hard to lose this
one there's no
there's just no way to make progress for
white well don't blow under case you
check
okay rook cheats okay bishop g6 there
was
i would i would make 20 moves here but i
would make 50 moves
and that wasn't me one-upping you that
was me talking about the times no no i i
you never one of me i i didn't interpret
it
i actually thirty-upped you if you you
know want to count
oh or 2050 wow that's very witty robert
i might
take that under consideration plagiarize
that in the future
good for you and what's going on we're
just repeating moves
shuffling or making a draw i think
yeah never making you draw though you
you and i we're going to make a draw
yeah we always make trust because we're
best of friends we're actually have we
had a decisive game robert i think we've
played
oh yeah we have berkeley yeah you cried
after the game
did i actually cry no but i might have
i mean i was young no i love how i said
it and you believed me and i felt bad
that i said it because you're like
oh wait a second this could be true and
now i feel like a bad person so
well you you you already know you are so
that's nothing nothing new under the sun
as they say
i'm pretty sure they don't say that so i
think i
i i remember the last time i cried after
after a game
i think it was um a world youth under
18.
i mean i'm not ashamed to say this
because everybody knows they put a lot
of
passion into the games i was playing
david anton ghiharo spanish grandmaster
now he's i think over 2700
yeah just about and i was already a gm
and
if i won i would contend for second
place if i drew i think it was
guaranteed third
and i did that thing for the only time
in my chest career
where i played the second move of a
variation rather than the first you know
what i mean
yeah and i was playing an inspired game
i sacked a queen it was
everything was going great and at some
point i just had this mental snafu
and uh yeah i definitely shed some tears
after that one but for the first time in
my life
i feel like i want to give you a hug but
you know oh
well yeah you know everybody gets better
with a trumpet
i put my arms in the hug motion so you
were supposed to just you know
fall right in there yeah okay okay i'll
cooperate i'll cooperate
um yeah that's that's a little
heartbreaking i'm not gonna lie to you
that
that pulls at the heart strings here the
last rounds are the worst the ones where
you lose the last round
that is the most crushing feeling
oh man that that hurts i i honestly
liked him much more when we had the
banter going on we pretended like we
didn't like each other now i'm hearing
sad stories about you crying
after i opened the door with a joke
about you crying which didn't actually
happen but you believe me
and that says something i got all
sentimental i always believe you know
well except when i don't believe you
which is most of the time and by the way
i think john is not believing a thing
greg is doing because he's about to win
another game
yes he's up at peace and well
he pushed him baby and that resulted in
winning material
and he's still got some winning to do
here but five minutes left in the match
probably time for two more games after
this one
can we get a candy john should play e4
out of respect
i know he should take matters into his
own hands yes
i'm very upset about this
and this is quite quite a shame you know
i
might go back to doing politics you know
because i had for so you know
john would play scandinavia you know
he's not playing and so you know this is
quite ridiculous
i was asking for one more kasparov but
that was my last one no more
oh man i wish uh wish we got scandi i
don't know what else to say here there
isn't much else to say
and really i what do you think looking
back
was a pivotal moment when greg do you
agree with my assessment that the first
two games actually played an outsized
role
in determining the the outcome of the
match or do you think there was another
moment that i'm missing
no i completely agree with you and
actually after we saw the third game
when john converted his advantage
i was already sort of hinting to this i
was like well i don't want to call it
you know match over already but when
john converts a position where he's
better and greg had two huge advantages
and was
not able to get the full point it
already felt like this was a match
that um john was in better shape for
and the hot hand isn't real so i don't
want anybody to me oh you know
he had the hot hand today but you know
jb
was in better form when it came down to
some of these critical moments
even greg offering that draw in the
fishman pawn
just goes to show that
it wasn't greg's day today yeah he just
didn't trust himself and sometimes
what is it you know people might wonder
what does it mean to be in pad form
or what does it mean when a very strong
player is still in bad form and
oftentimes that just means you're not
confident
in your own moves something is wrong
some some neurons are misfiring and you
just cannot quite
believe in the strength of your own
moves you take more time the effects of
that can be very insidious
but they're still very real
for sure and i haven't even looked at
the board once but now that i am looking
at it's actually a pretty interesting
position where i like greg's
chances i like yeah that pawn on a3
fixing the pawn on a2
and there we go rook c2 time to
infiltrate the first time we've seen
greg
actually have the pawn a3 usually it's
jb doing that to greg
but we finally get it and we do need to
scan the next game
or there will be a revolution robert
also
done it's pretty interesting that we got
the semis um
teddy and now greg both are losing
very one-sided matchups so what is it
about jb and elena
just it's clear that they deserve to be
in the final right what is it about
their styles or about the way they've
played these matches that have allowed
them to rook takes e4 rookie
even rook h4 in the mix there oh that's
a brave little move right there but
i guess queen takes queen and greg's
still of the upper seat well to answer
your question i think there's a couple
things right
first of all it's important to mention
john and alina have different styles
but what they share in common and i've
said this about two or three times so i
don't mean to sound like a broken record
but i do think
this is very important they almost never
beat themselves you can count on one
hand the amount of games where they made
a huge blunder or a string of games
where they played
well below their strength they're so
incredibly consistent and it's not like
they're necessarily better at
calculation than everybody else
but they're so much more consistent
their preparation is excellent
and both of them have a very clearly
defined strength john is a positional
monster and i mean monster his
positional strength i would say is
around 2600
and olena of course so sharp in tactics
and so well prepared in the opening
we saw queen b6 on thursday alina's game
in the first round game against teddy
john has his own big strength so these
are consistent players so hard to bring
down
and um it'll be a fascinating finale i
cannot
wait for that and something else to note
is that they seem to get
these time advantages and even if their
position is a bit shaky
in that near their opponent's time
travel they're the ones making the most
of uh those scrambles so i think this
one okay this one's over it's great you
have a final game
it better be e4 e4 please the final game
yes yes yes
teams candy lives that's right
oh man by the skin of their teeth and
john with a thumbs up greg with the
applause
thank god thank everybody this is for
the match i don't care
down your arms it is zero zero it's all
about this game here
it is scandy time and jon finally cracks
a smile let's see what's happening here
this is for the honor they are playing
for honor here oh man i'm
into this okay so we see the position
where white has the two bishops
we still have that those pincers right
b7 c6 f7 e6
but look at this setup with white i love
the bishops on in the center of the
bishop on d3 in particular
what do you do here is what do you go g4
g5 or 94 as you just played
i would go to i mean they have a very
similar structure to the karokon games
actually basically identical so
but it doesn't matter the important
thing is this came from us scandi had
this come from a karo khan
our excitement wouldn't be comparable i
would go h4 that's fine
greg should have done this i think
earlier in the match he had a couple of
chances g4
go for it break it open break it over oh
not g3
come on g4 yeah g4 was definitely the
move there you have to go for it
uh greg c3 it's too timid he's too
just too shy too timid here still g4 do
you know what this is this is respecting
the scandi
i which i never thought we would see i
mean he's also doubling in the effort
this is not bad let me be clear
um as obama would say let me be clear g4
you've got to play g4 just play g4 break
open
uh he's letting
john do everything he wants block k to
d6 square
and if you hit f5 for black all of a
sudden it's
yeah here comes f5 for black so ah greg
no you know i was ready to call this a
zero zero match and say the scandy
decides it
but now that this is happening i don't
want to oh actually bishop four pinning
tonight that's
useful good move but look at john's
position so solid greg had so many
chances to go g4
he's just not bullying not believing in
himself i think
and that's the theme of the match right
and queen e2
can be played just to go after the b5
pawn he goes b4 what is that on that
side of the board yes
look at that d3 square what about it
uh nothing just one or two no i'm
looking at it
white has i thought john would play c4
okay but instead he's just taking a free
pawn which i didn't notice
okay satisfied but you told me to look
at the details when i actually
did and i'm like what am i looking at
right now i made you look at least you
did and now that paul's on d6 and
well look at that bishop okay queen b3
oh
counter shot okay oh good green c4
yeah that would that would take the air
out of the position wait a second it's
only one check anything i'm actually
going to break open your kingdom i'll
work these g3 check
watch out okay but eight seconds for
greg and all of a sudden queen e5 comes
in
okay queenie five that's a good move
rookie
just take something queenie for check
you say such a john thing to do
it is the jonathan james it's the most
jonas thing ever to take on the gf3
there g4 pull him alina go g4 g5 me
hopefully move b4 and then g4
but the problem is oh look at john
driving him into the corner and queen g1
there's still bishop d5 g4 g4
uh greg's trying to go bishop queen f7
okay e2
queen d1 i'll put b3 here oh what a move
the scandy it's all about the swag
right now supreme stalemate ideas
yep f3 yeah f3 is
nice that way queen you choose me and it
ends with a checkmate
what a match moves on
we would see a quick break when we
return we will have both players in for
a postmatch interview
but it was all scandy all the way we'll
be right back with the i'm not jim
speeches championship brought to you by
[Music]
chess.com
well these two players gave the people
what they wanted so
greg i'm going to start with you sorry
the match did not go your way
but why did you take it to the last
bullet game to allow us candy
before i go on let me just say i just
want to get this out of the way
nobody clicked this part like you turn
off the clips
turned off what they even learned at
twitch john played a very good match
you might even say he outplayed me um
it was it was really difficult to solve
some of the the problems he was setting
during the event five minutes and three
minutes i just
i kept like i kept i felt like my
positions were okay and then i would
just kind of like he was very good at
like
complications even low on time um
so getting that out of the way and it's
gonna be a really exciting
final match between john and elena they
both they both look like they're playing
super well
but i i'm the one who didn't allow the
scandi
i mean you're playing b three chess
e4 e4 e4 e4 three-minute chess e4 e4
every game e4
where's where's the scandi well i was
saving my name
that's what people tuned in to see they
tuned in to see the scandi they were
robbed
of what they were here to see and only
because of my um
benevolence and generosity and the very
final bullet game
i gave him a chance to play it
well yeah
yeah i didn't feel it necessary to use
my a material in the five plus one
so you know i don't want to give away my
preparation i have another match with
alina which is going to be
extremely difficult which i know a
little bit about her style but
you know i got to keep some suspense i
did want to play it in the last game for
the fans because again this is hashtag
teamscandy it's not just me
so i did want to you know shout out to
you guys in the twitch and youtube chat
appreciate it
but in all seriousness uh it was it was
a great match
greg is a fantastic practical player i
think like
the thing that stands out about him is
he he makes consistently good decisions
especially in the opening and early
middle game
knows his prep well manages his time
great
i think i was down on the clock in many
of the five plus one games in particular
but uh i was able to navigate the the
games to positions that played in my
strengths i think and
got a little sloppy in the bullet but
overall i'm happy with the match for
sure
well i have a question for both of you
greg i'll start with you we felt like
in the first couple of games in the five
minute portion
you know you jumped out to an advantage
out of the opening you had some chances
to win the game do you feel like that
psychologically impacted your confidence
or was it more a case of
just kind of not going your way over the
board
um i don't think so honestly i felt
really confident because the first two
games i got good positions
i'm like if i keep getting the positions
you know i can i can win this match
um and then the third game he like out
technique me and then fourth game
i felt okay i was like i wanted the
points back but i was confident enough
at that point i'm like oh this guy is
nothing special i'm going to get great
positions every game eventually i'll
start winning some
um but it didn't really happen and can i
just say i've never lost a match by 10
like nine points and i had my opponent
just
talk as amazingly about how great i am
that was really that was impressive
they do say the best trash talk is when
the person is being really nice
yeah no but i'm i'm not anything for the
cameras i just thought uh
yeah time management wise i think uh i
have a ways to go i think i'm inferior
to greg and blitz in that department but
i can make up for it in other aspects
you played very well
thank you well you're such gentlemen
well john
hey guys it's hey john it's guys the
guys have a question for you
exactly well you weren't saying that too
much in this match but
you mentioned that you are a bit
familiar with alina's
style that is a final that everyone is
looking forward to without revealing any
secrets from
bartholomew's kitchen um what can you
tell us about
alina's style and how are you going to
attempt to exploit
some of the downsides in her style and
in her play if there are any
yeah so i in this tournament i've been
taking it match by match
i know that's uh sports cliche what or
what not but um
yeah i i was expecting to go far in this
tournament
and on the other side of the bracket
after that match with uh kristoff i
gotta
i gotta say like i didn't underestimate
alina but i thought there was a good
chance that eric rosen would
take her out but she's gotten stronger
in this format i think as this
tournament has
gone along and i think quite clearly
she's the strongest classical player in
the event i think she's 24 94 feed a
i mean very close to gm strength
now this format it does it does play to
other strengths too so i like my chances
as far as what i'm expecting in terms of
preparation i guess that remains to be
seen i'm gonna
just enjoy this victory for a few days
and then get down to business
hey man man name response i mean
greg um i don't even know what to ask
you right now because
john is just he's just a kind guy like
does it does that you know make you want
to root for him in the finals are you
going to root for alina
no it's all a trick he's not you hear
what he said about his a-game
yeah that was all another let's not make
him out to be a saint just yet
well saints have to die first right so
you know
who do you who do you have you you like
to make odds who do you have
as the favor in the final between john
and lena john very strong player
but i have to have to root for her i'm
sorry
oh and i hope i hope there's a scandy
and i hope she crushes it
i do want to offer another olive branch
so it's very possible i'll be coming out
with another course on the scandy
i am the co-founder of chessable check
us out and uh greg you will be the first
one to get a free copy i just wanted
[Laughter]
and i know you already patronized our
site we appreciate it but i'm gonna give
you a free copy
oh man that is such a kind gesture see
that is the type of you know
kind insult that hurts way more than the
foul mouth
uh you know saying could in part but
um john do you delete like courses that
you get
man john i did want to ask you something
because
greg did have two almost winning
positions in the first two games i mean
the first game he was winning in a rook
end game
uh in rook and three versus rook and one
you end up holding that um
but did you gain confidence with the
fact that you were holding
positions that looked like he was on the
verge of victory and in winning
positions where you had you know
advantages
yeah once i got a two-game margin i
started feeling really confident
um holding that draw in the first game i
mean actually if you guys recall my
match with lawrence trent it went almost
exactly the same way in the first game i
was just getting ground down i was worse
as white i was behind on the clock
and i had to defend a rook ending this
time i had uh two fewer pawns but still
managed to hold but
yeah i mean i i think i got a little
fortunate in some of the time scrambles
uh the third game was nice i really
liked that game the same color bishop
ending
yep the game where i had i think five
versus four
and knight versus bishop i was upon just
grinding away i had
like point three seconds on my clock i
looked down and i almost flagged and
uh i saw greg offered to draw that i
might have flagged if he hadn't offered
a draw
oh you were down on time surprise yeah i
was i was like my brain was
jumbled at that point i was just like
help i completely locked
lost track of time in that game yeah and
well did you feel like that was a real
bailout for you because at that point
the match was still close
and the trajectory of the game was
clearly going greg's favor with the
bishop against the knight that was stuck
in the corner so do you feel like
you could breathe a sigh of relief and
even if things really weren't
going your way as that one was going
downhill quickly you still had what it
took to
kind of withstand that pressure yeah for
sure i mean when you
get even a half point there when just a
moment prior it looked like you were
going down for sure
uh that definitely helps and yeah after
the five plus one four
portion i mean i already had a pretty
big lead i was feeling very very
confident
well greg if you started this match over
what would you do differently
let's see i would win the first game
more scandi i would maybe like figure
out like some better lining like some
more exciting lighting in satori you
know i kind of thought this line was
okay but
it's not my style exactly the way it was
more john style
boring position yeah i should i should
have had like i should have had like
more than one lining satori i should
have like three or four like i had a lot
of stuff prepared against like regular
d4 stuff
but i was ready for the grunt foul um
as you saw in the first game yeah i got
a bad feeling about that after the first
game so
because when you when you pause even in
a five plus one game for
20 seconds let's say in the opening to
figure out what line you're going to
play that adds up so quick
so i just thought avoid that altogether
then i started having good results so i
didn't see any reason to switch from the
tory
makes sense well you know thank you both
for what was a very entertaining match
even though it didn't live up to the
promise of a scandinavian battle i feel
like
you know we were excited to see in the
final game but
we are a little disappointed if we're
honest with you both so
johnny material robert you got to keep
it under wraps there's still another
match to be played job's not over yet
indeed and we're all looking forward to
congratulations john
good match greg thank you it's been a
pleasure playing in the sternum
yeah well thanks for having me thank you
we'll see you in the final john and
thanks to you both and
with that we bring up the bracket here
to remind everybody of well
who is john facing he's facing alina
captions he said
when she beat christoph zelecki in the
first match he was like hey let's notice
alina she's obviously a super strong
classical player but
maybe a little shaky in the blitz
portion but then she beats eric rosen
largely because the bullet section goes
on to crush teddy coleman
in the semis and i mean donya john
elena in the final you're making a
pre-match prediction right now you're
going to think more about it i know
but right now who you got i mean i was
very impressed with john's performance
today and i was so impressed alina's
match against teddy is something that i
will not forget for a long time and
elena just came out
firing game after game finding
incredible tactical resource it is going
to be a case
of unstoppable force against a movable
object and i predict a very close match
i know i say that every time
i really think it's going to be a very
close match i cannot wait for that final
both of these
are players at the top of their game
and um we're just going to have to see
i'm going to refrain from a prediction
for the first time because i really have
no idea it could go either way
and there might be overtime i think that
match will be very close because
both players sort of had a similar path
towards this final
and they dominated their respective
semi-final matchups that came
as a surprise to me at least and with
alina catching
up taking on john bartholomew i don't
know just like you it sounds like
cop-out but i'm really unsure
no should be the favorite there because
they both ultimately
won by big margins as john himself said
alina has only been getting better
she had a tough first round match and
since then she's been improving
and john's been dominant throughout the
entire competition
indeed i think everybody is so looking
forward to this match
i certainly am and today's match was
another
very very entertaining match not as
close as we predicted
but i had a great time and um robert i
will say
on balance you were a net positive in
terms of energy my experience well i'm
glad if you don't want to go for plus
minus in the box for that at least end
up with a plus there but
uh you know it's been a fun time for
sure and john bartholomew and alina cash
and sky will face each other
in the finals that will be scheduled
sometime this week of course the match
just finished so
john will have to talk about his
schedule and see if it match up with the
linos but we will have that finale
coming to you soon
in the meantime enjoy the rest of your
night uh if you're somewhere where it's
already
you know early in the morning the wee
hours i'll get up
get ready for a good sunday but thank
you so much to everybody who's tuned in
for this i am not gm speechless
championship brought to you by chess.com
because without your support we couldn't
make it happen i know that donnie and i
both are gaining energy from it and
indeed for other events like the
european online chess championship
it'll tide you over more than tied you
over before the finals so
don't forget about those other events we
thank each and every one of you for
tuning in we had a great community here
a great chat
and it certainly makes our experience a
lot more entertaining
and i guess i i would be making a
mistake not to mention one more thing
that there is
a um match-up with danny wrench
and anish hiri so another one of the
adopted danny
events will will be very short i think
it's on monday if i'm not mistaken but
the point is it raises money for a
adoption foundation dave thomas
organization
so tune into that see danny likely get
adopted
but until then enjoy yourselves
everybody stay safe and bye everybody
happy
[Music]
you